a voicemail from joe biden to hunter
biden has leaked and it shows that joe
was calling trying to talk to his son
about his business dealings with china
something he's repeatedly denied saying
he's never talked to hunter about his
business deals or anything like that wow
so corrupt and the expo uh the exposes
keep coming because of hunter biden's
laptop i'm just going to start counting
down until all the media outlets come
out and say it's fake news it's not
really joe biden it must be a deep fake
whatever it's being reported by a news
guard certified outlet so we will be
reporting it we also have big news
one million democrats over the past year
have quit the party and join the
republicans
i think it's simple i think people are
quitting and joining the republicans
because the democrats have lost their
minds however some people fear what's
actually happening is that democrats are
jumping parties in order to screw over
republicans in their primaries
which is just weird
so i suppose we'll talk about that plus
we've got this crazy story people are
freaking out over a bunch of these
lgbtqia2plus
flags lining some streets in the uk
which just
generally kind of freaky and then we
have uh
man this one's crazy well i'll just put
it this way instead of focusing on cnn
and the psychotic things they've said
we've got the executive branch outright
rejecting the judicial branch the
legislative branch doing the exact same
thing at the highest levels of
government
the federal government is being ripped
apart over roe v wade and uh
it's getting crazy so we'll get into all
that but before we get started my
friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your ageless multi-collagen from
biotrust again at
strongerbonesandlife.com
you can secure your supply of ageless
multi-collagen for up to 51 off today
when you go there you'll get a 60-day
money-back guarantee the healthy aging
support of collagen in its ideal forms
five key types of collagen you need from
four different sources essential to
optimally support an array of full body
full body benefits hydrolyzed collagen
peptides mean better and faster
digestibility to support the maximum
benefits so collagen is what you need
for your joint your hair your skin your
nails and you may have noticed that i'm
currently wearing a wrist brace because
i think i broke my wrist so i will be
eating lots of this and it's very
difficult to use the computer but i'm
grateful that i have this stuff and i
will consume more hopefully that will
heal up
so
for every order today biotrust will
donate a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org today
biotrust has provided over 5 million
meals to hungry kids please help them
hit their goal of 6 million meals this
year there is nearly no odor or taste
unlike bone broth and other collagen
supplements and no clumping you'll get
free shipping with every order free vip
live health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order over at
strongerbonesandlife.com shout out
biotrust thank you for sponsoring the
show but don't forget to go to
timcast.com become a member support our
work directly we put up an exclusive
members only show monday through
thursday and as a member you will get
access to that you'll be supporting our
journalists and our endeavors as we
expand the operation we're gonna be
working on some documentaries those are
pretty expensive but with your support
we can make it happen and you're
supporting our infrastructure we are we
are supporting companies that are
building resilient systems to fight back
against censorship so support that
alternate market don't support big tech
i know we're on youtube but we're
working on a bunch of things right now i
can't say too much
with that being said
to oh smash the like button subscribe to
the channel share the show and with that
being said we are joined today by greg
ellis
greg who are you who am i i'm greg ellis
uh star of pirates of the caribbean
there you go yeah yes and a few other
movies a few other movies yes what's
your what's what's like the biggest or
your favorite movie you've been in i
think the pirates movies were fun
because you get to travel the world and
you get to you know play with swords and
you know
tap into all of that kid stuff rehearse
with penelope cruz we won't tell that
story
did you guys shoot a lot on the boats
yeah in fact the first movie that we
filmed it was uh
we the first scenes we filmed were in
san pedro
uh and then the budget went up a little
bit and we were able to actually go to
the caribbean and uh around the around
the world yeah so you've also written
quite a bit you've uh covered
extensively the johnny depp issue i i
understand or yeah i wrote a book called
the respondent exposing the cartel
family law where i kind of talk about
the legal system and family law in
general and
you know the one branch of our legal
system that doesn't provide a
presumption of innocence or due process
uh which should uh family law and um the
silver bullet of the false allegation of
dv which was used against johnny in 2016
um
and uh been following that case and talk
about that a lot and obviously you know
we've we've seen the jury's verdict and
um hopefully we'll bring about change
you know right on well thanks for
joining us it should be fun we also got
sheamus coughlin shame is calling i'm
shameless coughlin wearing the same
shirt you guys saw me wearing on friday
you know pretty terrible but i promise i
wasn't wearing it all weekend we were
traveling things got crazy we were out
in new york it was a wonderful time
i'm seamus coughlin of freedom tunes we
make animated cartoons released one
every week we actually released two last
week
and i just launched a website called
freedomtunes.com if you guys want to go
over there for five bucks a month you'll
get an extra cartoon each week and you
will also be supporting independent
content and helping us get uh free from
big tech awesome hot thanks hey guys
back from new york city if you didn't
see the show we did the uh mines
festival of ideas and if you want to see
the show you can at festival.minds.com
not of course now after the show uh
there's a link from there james o'keefe
confronted ben burgess backstage causing
this huge commotion and then on our
panel the whole thing was like this
argument you should have been it was
like wwf like old school well wwe now
fort saucy it was hot sitting between
it was wonderful wonderful bill thanks
for putting it on and the whole minds
crew and the beacon theater everybody it
was just a fantastic event it was great
great to be there i'm looking forward to
the next one uh
and uh we'll see you soon all right i am
also here in the corner pushing buttons
i realize i never introduced myself
either i am lydia i'm sour patch lids
all i do is push buttons and bring on
the guests we're gonna have a great show
i'm super excited to have greg ellis i i
realized a while ago like i never say
mine yeah i was like wait i don't either
i never introduced myself
welcome to the show how are they going
to know that your name's tim yeah i
don't know i don't know maybe i don't
know my last name whatever
all right everybody let's jump into this
first story
uh you know we were originally going to
lead with the big political story but
then i was like no wait we got to talk
about this leaked audio this is crazy
from the daily mail exclusive quote i
think you're clear
yeah what does that mean
voicemail from joe biden to hunter about
new york times report on his chinese
business dealings proves he did speak to
his son about his relationship with
criminal dubbed the spy chief of china
yo man
i just i i'm not surprised and i kind of
don't i can it get any worse for joe
biden his legacy his son
when this comes out and it's like oh
here's audio of joe biden himself
talking to his kid about his business
it's a voicemail i'm just not surprised
and i don't know if you can move the
needle from like zero to less than zero
in terms of like
faith in this man as president but let's
let's read a little bit more i'm i'm i'm
um
fumbling around the mouse because my my
wrist is probably broken so uh you have
to bear with me as i'm trying that
navigate this this episode is brought to
you by family mouse that's right yeah
that's right that's our sponsor all
right president joe biden spoke with
hunter about his business dealings with
a chinese criminal and his son dubbed
the spy chief of china a voicemail to
his son reveals so i'll put it this way
we'll play it in a second
either this was the extent that joe
talked to hunter he sent him a voicemail
and said i think you're clear and that
was it
presumably leaving a voicemail means you
intend to talk to them in greater detail
so it sounds like this is evidence he
did
at least try to talk to his son and
brought up the issue and told him using
the clear i think it's circumstantial
evidence they probably had a longer
conversation about let me play this
audio for you right now
hey palace dad it's 8 15.
um
oh you can get a chance give me a call
no it doesn't hurt you
just want to talk to you i thought the
article released a thing on online
that's going to be printed 21 times it's
good
and you can clear
and uh
anyway um
if you get a chance give me a call
and that's it so yeah scrolling away
because the next auto play is hunter
naked and i don't want to play that oh
wow i mean
shocking revelation that joe biden does
know what day of the week it is yeah i
know i was surprised well that's a
four-year-old phone call i believe sorry
oh man okay all right okay i got a
couple issues they frame this as it's
proof they say proof in the in the
article title which it's evidence like
you said circumstantial this is proof
well it could have been doctored which
doesn't sound like it was could have
been doctored no and also there's no
context what is he even talking about
you're in the clear what's he talking
about i don't know if i read this so so
i'll put it this way perhaps um i would
be willing to entertain the daily mail
is completely lying to us about this
but the daily mail has the laptop
they've they've been going through it
the emails have been verified at the
very least the new york times has
confirmed this
it's a question of do you trust your
source well newsguard says the daily
mail is certified as not publishing
false news
and what more can i say if they say that
they got this audio they know the time
stamp on it they know when this article
came out what it was about
i think they've done their work and
they've made the assessment now you can
choose not to believe it that's fine
some people sometimes news outlets lie
and quite frequently in fact i think
this is more likely than not absolutely
true especially considering we already
know that that joe biden lied about this
joe biden was talking you know asked
like do you you know hunter biden the
business dealings and he's like i don't
talk about any of this stuff and then
photos emerged of joe with hunter and
his associates
playing golf or something it's like come
on dude we know you're lying come on man
come on man that's right how did daily
mail make the association here that he
was talking about these chinese
associates when he said you're in the
clear from like how do they make the
extrapolation from the voicemail joe
called hunter on december 12th 2018
saying that he wanted to talk to him
about uh talk to him after reading a new
york times story about hunter's dealings
the chinese oil giant perhaps there's
more to the call or more calls they
didn't release perhaps they simply know
the time stamp happened right when a big
story specifically article yeah he
didn't mention an article yeah he said
it in the in the text yeah yeah like
like joe actually said
just give me a call nothing urgent just
want to talk uh talk to you
he says i read the article released
online it's going to be printed tomorrow
a15 you know
okay yeah yeah so no i think i think ian
brings up a good point you know but but
i'm just going to say i i'm i believe
the daily mail did their due diligence
and they they have this stuff from the
laptop we know the laptop's real is it
true that joe biden flew hunter to china
on air force two yes so okay for him to
be flying his son to china around the
world putting him on the board of
barisma this energy company in ukraine
well i don't know i don't say joe i
didn't put him on that okay maybe he
didn't but to say that that this is hap
that he's on the board that he's been
flown to china i mean he's flying china
but that he's not involved with his
business somehow is insane i mean that's
that's that's involvement if you're
flying the guy there well they shared a
bank account
is this confirmed
tim said it multiple times on air i know
that we um we have this phone call which
is great but it just seems to me at this
point we should
be able to have an investigation there
should have been an investigation before
this came out there will be when he's
not president you think so i don't know
if people wanted the political
persecution or if we just should do it
regardless of political persecution
ideals like it just needs to be
investigated because of sitting
president
my first thought was what what you said
you know a little bit skeptical but i'm
i'm still reeling from the fact that i
think that audio is doctored because
that's that's joe biden stringing
together quite a coherent sentence
that's good evidence it's not real not
real yeah right if the daily mail was
really trying to fabricate it they
needed to make him say come on man a
couple times
maybe some gibberish words or for
sure would sell it word salad yeah and
then i'd believe it no but it's four
years ago
so you know he's only gotten worse since
then
and um
you know the thing about joe is that he
can when you get old like him you can
probably handle a few hours a day
but it's what's it called sundowning or
sunsetting yeah yep sundowning as like
you're awake for a few hours you're spry
and then within a couple hours you're
just
ready for grants
yeah that happens to me now yeah wow i'm
sorry maybe you need more vitamin b
maybe yeah b12 b6
well maybe the healthy aging support of
collagen there you go that's for sure
wait someone tell me more about that
that's right it's wonderful thanks for
watching the show everyone
flavorless yeah yeah that's really good
i have some in my coffee right now by
the way my dad's been taking collagen
apparently it's extremely good for your
skin
he's had skin reparations in his older
and he's like he's 70 and he's like man
my cuts are healing better now dude it's
great look at this from nbc news they
say at the time it seemed mildly
noteworthy but not particularly unusual
then vice president joe biden traveling
to china on an official visit bringing
his son on air force two
so it's like
yo
this family is corrupt and we've known
this yeah i know that's why that's why i
almost didn't want to lead with the
story and i was like
you know oh yeah more more leaks about
joe biden being dirty
and shocking what's next what happens if
there is more evidence comes out i mean
what would you all want to happen oh he
should be impeached outright 100 so we
had um
troy nails on congressman from texas
and uh i asked him i was like this might
be a hard question but should the
republicans win in november will you
impeach joe biden without skipping a
beat he's like yes of course absolutely
joe biden has done so much that the very
least
is circumstantial evidence war or
probable cause warning a very serious
investigation i think what we know about
what what joe biden's done is completely
impeachable and if not i mean criminal
so you know we saw the uh the democrats
come out and say that donald trump
engaged in a quid pro quo with ukraine
or was it with yeah i was with ukraine
to try and dig up dirt on joe biden the
reality of the story is that donald
trump uncovered joe biden engaging in a
quid pro quo with ukraine to fire a
prosecutor who happened to have been
investigating the company where joe
biden's son was working
i'm not saying he did it because his son
was working there but those things are
all facts that alone is like joe biden
should be impeached he's on video saying
he did it he's laughing about it but he
didn't do it while he was president so
can you impeach the president for
something they did before they were
president he was vice president
yes well i mean he's lying about it
absolutely
absolutely
he should be investigated for it
the the assumption is that and now he's
giving how many billions of dollars to
ukraine so i mean that's just right
there the united states being like oh we
got to give 70 billion dollars to
ukraine oh geez i wonder why maybe it's
because it's payback now where the
president's son was on the board of an
energy company and the president's
sending money to the com to the country
this is so crazy it's it's just
remarkable that we know these things to
be true but this country is so full of
vapid angry ignorant and arrogant people
that we are stuck here with him as
president
what do you do i mean what's he he's
going to tell us to go back to the crown
is what he said
i say
i challenge you to a jewel you people
you people
all you sorts of people i don't know who
you are um no i think you know from the
moment i mean i followed the primaries
and and it was clear to me that that joe
biden didn't stand a chance and it was
the dnc i mean they picked him you know
he was i think it was fourth place in
carolina so you know and then you know
to pick camilla as the as the vice
president and to pick her because she's
quote a black woman it's like well why
don't you just pick the best person and
even if it happens to be a woman who
happens to be black just let that just
be there and she can take some delight
in but we you know same with the supreme
court nominee uh it just it it's all i
don't know
it's it's devoid of of principle yeah of
course logic well so biden had promised
if i'm not mistaken that he was going to
select a woman of color to be his vice
president that was the debate with
bernie wasn't it when he said yeah and
part of what's so hilarious about that
is he obviously did it to pander to
progressives but i don't know a
progressive who can stand kamala harris
i know i don't know anyone that's ever
told her
exactly i i met a lady and she was like
i love kamala and i was like why you're
the only person it's her laugh isn't it
it's so endearing it's very contagious
it's like hillary was bad and then
kamala comes along what's up with that
they're like it's because you hate women
that's what's up right now what is a
woman
no idea with hillary if you ask kamala
you know
the hillary thing was well the obama
thing was there was identity politics
about him being like the first black
president i think and he was like you
know half black half white whatever but
then the the identity politics really
started grinding with hillary clinton
when they were like i'm with her it was
all about her i mean not that you can
say i'm with him i'm with him but you
wouldn't know which hymn you're talking
about
maybe it was just but it seemed very
much like it's her time it's her time
and it wasn't like it's her time it's
her time it's about the fact that which
is such an embarrassing thing to say
like like mom said i can play video
games now like it's her time like it's
her turn this is something she's just in
line for
it's funny because like with the roe v
wade decision getting overturned i was
just like you know this is hillary
clinton's fault right
like
so uh you know the old parable of this
this frog and the scorpion there's a
funny meme i posted where it's like the
frog says but now we will surely both
drown and the scorpion says lol lmao i
thought that was hilarious because like
but uh it's basically you know the frog
i corrected him i'm wrong but you know
you know the story the frog is like
vaguely there's a river and the
scorpion's like help me across the river
and the frog's like no you'll sting me
he's like nah i won't because then we'll
both die and then the scorpion jumps on
the frog's like okay good point scorpion
jumps on his back they start swimming
the scorpion stings them and the frog's
like but now we'll both die and it says
yes but it isn't my nature
something like that right so like donald
trump got three conservative supreme
court justices that is exactly what you
would expect the republicans to do if
they won we knew that's what they wanted
to do they said they wanted to do it so
how do you prevent that
well
hillary clinton was how you make it
happen people despise that woman and so
when bernie sanders was rising in
popularity the democrats were like
better to nuke everything about our
platform
because it's hillary's turn and bernie's
bad
than to allow you know then then to to
allow bernie to win imagine being
hillary clinton and you couldn't beat
donald trump and then you see joe biden
do it oh
man
that's
especially with him not campaigning yeah
yeah like literally hiding in a basement
what did trump call him joe hayden
he was learning his lines
the vp
traditionally right
runs for president can you see that
happening with them with uh
oh yeah
you're right
it's interesting
but it isn't she would also go
yes
but you mentioned that that the vp
usually runs for president isn't it
interesting that joe didn't alter the
obama administration they said it was
because his son died
okay he said that's understandable but
uh they didn't want bernie to win
because that was like an insurgency
but you know if hillary if if ruth bader
ginsburg retired this wouldn't happen
roberts would have been on the side of
keeping roe v wade
she could have retired
obama could have appointed a liberal
justice maybe i mean you know some a lot
of people said that i'm kind of like
yeah maybe not because mcconnell still
blocked garland anyway so there's if i
don't think obama could have got anybody
in if maybe if she retired
very early on
but the issue is simple
if hillary did not run
trump would not have won
like
one but but not even bernie like anyone
else
it's like trump
won by i think 88 000 votes across three
states which gave him a big electoral
college lead hillary clinton it was her
turn she wanted it everybody should be
yelling at her
or the dnc i'm still getting over the
fact that the the man who was on a
reality show when you're fired every
week became i mean did that that really
happened and here we are now with this
teleprompter president
who who really you know i've said for
some time he looks like he's just not
cognitively all there he doesn't just
look like it he acts like it yeah yeah
and he talks like it and if it lock if
it talks like a duck walks like a duck
but you got a duck yeah yeah no it's
true quack quack if the president speaks
like he's mentally impaired walks like
he's mentally impaired and has an
expression on his face like he's
mentally impaired we're in a lot of
this isn't a trouble
thing either this isn't like you know
the the like
i would think that it is
well it is but it shouldn't be i mean
it's just a rational reasonable you look
at this either it's an intravenous drip
of vodka from seven in the morning or or
there's something cognitively in decline
with his brain and i don't say that in a
mean-spirited way but he literally can't
string a sentence together with her and
then occasionally the the rashes of
temper i mean when he was on the
campaign trail was that worker on the
ship on the factory floor who was just
asking him about i think it was assault
weapons
and he was like in his face and losing
there was just a you know what it is
it's when people have uh
like dementia that's right or
alzheimer's rage can occur because
their brain isn't giving them access to
the information they need and it's very
frustrating it's very frustrating to
have someone say something to know you
know the answer but be unable to put
together so you just start very quickly
i'm just angry like i can't do this yeah
do you think those around him are like
close and is in a circular aware and
know something that we don't about a
medical diagnosis or or they just think
oh he's just old and a bit doddery oh
come on they know more than me i don't
know yeah yeah like i i think there may
be a diagnosis i don't know
but it's not a secret everybody knows
this guy's brain is completely fried
and he's the president of the united
states of america he should be relieved
of command his his surrender in
afghanistan was the it was the largest
military blunder in american history i
think probably
it lost i mean honestly
there's a there's a lot of mistakes
we've made in the united states but i
kind of agree
abandoning bagram air force base in the
middle of the night without informing
the afghan security forces and letting
it get looted by the citizens is just
like beyond how does that happen how
does that happen with all of the chain
of command i mean the generals along the
way is someone going to speak up and
well there's two there's two ideas one
is the more conspiratorial they did it
on purpose
but then you need a bunch of evidence
i think the simple the simple answer is
joe biden's sitting in the situation
room
and his eyes are half closed he's gone
and then everyone's sitting around them
and they're all looking at each other
like do i do something you heard and we
got her
no no they're just like
should i should i do something what do i
do no no you didn't say it i don't know
what to do let's just get out of here
and they get up and walk out they're
like i have no idea
no idea what to do
and so they just it's just chaos
it's also possible that joe biden says
you know we know that he was speaking to
i think the g7 and he kept saying libya
instead of syria
it's possible he was saying he meant to
say you got to evacuate the civilian
airport and he said military airport
because his brain doesn't work and they
went okay
for all we know he was like you gotta
you know we gotta get people out of
there you gotta uh you gotta
evacuate the uh airport uh
civilians you know but wouldn't someone
have pushed back and said mr president
we can't i mean that that happens
doesn't it maybe
but maybe i i gotta be honest i can
imagine joe biden saying something we've
seen him speak imagine his situation
room what do we do sir
use the airport you got to evacuate you
got to get them out you know the
civilians and then they're like the
civilian airport get them out get them
on like okay i think you're being kind i
think he made a bad military command he
he thought that because we said i'm
saying his brain screwed up because we
said we were going to be out by a
certain date he was like virtue
signaling okay we said we were going to
do it let's follow through even if a
hundred thousand people die with their
heads cut off uh let's do what we said
we're gonna dude it's wartime you lie in
war you do what you need to do to get
these people safe and this
guy
is not capable
i'm just saying i think like you've got
two airports
the military
and the civilian
and he very easily could have said the
wrong word
and then he gets angry and so when
someone said sir do you mean to evacuate
the bagram just do it come on man and
they're like okay okay
whatever and then the military leaders
we've seen the joint chiefs they're
woken stupid so they're probably just
like
i'm willing to bet
we have fil the government is full of
careerists who are just like i am not
going to stick my neck out i'm going to
give my few years that i have to do to
get the medals and then i'm out whatever
biden says is on him not me just do it
no point getting fired
right you got a crackpot as the
president he'll just go what are you
gonna do right you're fired and it's
like okay people i'm not i'm not doing
it just do what he says people gotta
listen to tim kennedy talk to rogan
about this because tim went to
afghanistan with like uh worked with i
think it was the us department of
defense or he worked with the government
to pull pull people out after the bedlam
began of the surrender and the madness
and the media showed us like the plane's
coming in the plane's going out you see
people falling out of the planes that
are trying to hang on for their life but
what it didn't show is the surrounding
area outside of the airport where people
were getting cut up where women were
trying to get their babies inside and
they couldn't so they're throwing them
over what was barbed wire
it it's and it was happening in mass for
weeks he was there for two weeks ten
days and he said he just kept getting
worse the longer he was there and then
he left
maybe maybe the issue is this
you know does it really matter why it
happened but it happened and it's joe
biden's leadership that has failed us
and there's no reason to try and make
excuses for why it happened other than
to say this guy's got to go
he's gotta be impeached convicted
yes some people are like but then you
get kamala and i'm like i don't know is
ruthless better or worse than deranged
it's better better way better
i feel i feel like it's this way kamala
harris may gut and loot the system for
her personal benefit but the system has
to exist for her for her to benefit from
it
joe biden's
deranged his son's a crackhead
and it's like well he could burn the
whole place down playing with matches
so it's like two years of the crazy lady
who's gonna
loot the coffers for herself at least
she needs the coffers to still exist
yeah i mean i don't know i just want
everyone to consider the fact that this
is someone who given their mental state
should not be trusted with a butter
knife
and that's true he has access to the
button
he killed so many he's curious he's
given like a plastic circle to butter
his bread like when he's doing arts and
crafts i hope they give him kids
scissors i hope he has like the plastic
ones and you know he's doing arts and
crafts would be a great cartoon where
he's like scissors won't cut paper
and they're like joe you know you can't
have metal scissors
well let's jump to the story we have
from timcats.com
more than one million voters one million
leave democrats and switch to gop
democrats urge biden to change course to
avoid being demolished in the midterms
okay
with 134 days into the midterm elections
no outcome is guaranteed but the new
data is a fresh warning to democrats now
many people are arguing
that this is democrats joining the gop
to sabotage the primaries perhaps
i think that's probably a tiny fraction
of it i think people don't don't think
like that the average person wakes up
they go to their job at the bodega or at
the mall or the restaurant or they're a
carpenter tradesman and they're not
sitting there thinking like how can i
sabotage the rival political party
they're just like why is my gas so
expensive right i'm voting republican
this time and that's it
what do you think why do you think
people are quitting the party i think
what i've
i think we're you know driving up here i
was thinking about yonkin and what
happened with him uh in virginia and i
think people that that vote transcended
politics i think parents through covert
had seen for the first time the
education system the disarray of that
the introduction of crt to young kids
and um you know sex ed to six seven
eight-year-olds and they were just done
but just done and their values uh just
had it so i think um you know you can
only drink so much woca cola before
before you get you know you just passed
it and over it i mean i was woke about
seven years ago and you have to break
through beyond that pre-existing belief
system and you do when you finally see
enough of it you go this is nonsense
this i'm being fed propaganda not news
and and this
ideological extremism post-modern
progressive whatever you want to call it
this intersectionality is so out there
that you know i said before you know i
didn't leave the left the left left me
and where did it leave me in in kind of
limbo going well well am i because i can
remain we don't have to affiliate we
don't have to i'm not a registered
anything in england but in america it's
you know it's obviously a very different
uh system and i just think um people
have had it
they've just had enough
you know
no no no please i was going to say it's
funny that you know elon musk posts that
meme of the left moving further and
further left and that was colin wright's
main by the way right exactly exactly
i've said this
you've said it
elon musk is saying it i just don't
understand at what point will the
democrats will the liberals on the left
realize there is a recurring pattern
here where a whole bunch of people are
like the left is leaving me behind and
they're like so what
okay sheamus is exactly where he's
always been as a conservative pretty
much i've moved a bit over the years on
different things i've actually probably
yeah yeah i mean i used to be more
libertarian but yeah pretty much the
point is socially for sure if with that
colin wright meme posted by elon
if we as like former left liberals are
now being left behind
politically we are closer to
conservatives than the modern left
what do they think is going to happen in
terms of the vote they'll cease to exist
they're they're lopping themselves off
from political discourse i think what
they what we're seeing here and it's
interesting that you mentioned junkin
and those parents because i think what
they've done possibly without realizing
it or maybe without caring about it is
they've turned parents
writ large they've turned parents into a
voting block and i don't think they've
realized how unbelievably damaging this
is going to be that's insane because
they have they've done it and they've
turned them all against them and they've
told them you're terrorists go away we
don't want to hear what you have to say
we have your kids now we see as well i
think from the alphabet you know the
identity politics eventually devours
itself and that's what we're seeing with
the lgbtq you know it goes on and on and
on and they're fighting amongst
themselves and and it's that you know i
don't know the liberal elites though
they're just gonna keep
you know living in their ivory towers
and making money and pretending and
purporting to be fighting for
you know the working man and
dis-impoverished neighborhoods and when
really that it's quite the opposite
that's going on that's what i see we
live in the upside downs with a lot of
hip-hop moral hypocrisy seems to be rife
at the moment there's uh
bill crystal right he's a neocon
and he tweeted out something about how
the supreme court is extreme or
radicalized for overturning roe v wade
when he actually wrote something like 25
years ago an article saying row must go
so how is it that the neocons of of
eight years ago all of a sudden are just
agreeing with democrats here's an
example the lincoln project we are going
to restore the party of lincoln from you
know after donald trump donald trump
loses and they go we're
we're basically democrats we're just
here to dragon republicans come on so
these people who claim to be republicans
claim to support these values
are now all of a sudden supporting
democratic policy and values like
jennifer rubin's a great example
conservative writer and often she's like
yay stacy abrams yay democrats and it's
like do you have principles or are you
just drifting realistically democrat and
republican are just jackets uh anyone
just cause you're wearing a coat with a
name on it a word on it doesn't mean
that it's gonna make you think a
different way it doesn't matter what you
call yourself but they do people are
those people they are thinking a
different way bill crystal was always
looking for i mean he was a proponent of
the war in iraq he loved the invasion
and conquest now democrats have a
they have a higher approval rating for
george w bush than than republicans do
for some reason
but you have uh
my point is
these people are exposing themselves as
never having actually believed in
anything
like raw row is bad it's like bro you
wrote the article on why row must go and
now also you're saying it's bad yeah
it's because you didn't like trump you
didn't want to be a part of that so you
joined the democrats that's it now now
your id your ideology was always
immaterial irrelevant you're just
claiming to support things for the sake
of making money that's it
when you have that
you have the democrats looking to young
people and saying
we got to get their vote what do we do
and they say well these people are in
favor of a lot of really weird things
you know like they're castrating kids
and then democrats are like will we get
the vote they're like yeah but you're
probably going to lose all the rest of
them they're like let's go for it
now you have loudoun county parents
electing yunkan because they're like i'm
out whatever this is nuts i don't want
to be involved in it
i think people are switching parties for
that reason and i think the narrative of
it's to sabotage
republicans is is nonsense i think some
do but i think it's a minority tiny tiny
fraction i agree with that and and you
know loudoun county i i saw some of
those school board hearings
they weren't i mean talk about nuts
i mean there was one i think it was one
guy who was entering and he got tackled
to the ground and handcuffed and and he
was made out to be some kind of you know
neo-nazi alt-right crazy purse when then
you look into the story you find out
that he was actually his daughter was
allegedly raped in the restroom by i
think it was proven that she was right
right maybe yeah and and that's the kind
of thing where i think parents are
looking at that and going you know what
no enough
you know you don't you the state
shouldn't or the government shouldn't
step in and tell a parent how to raise
their kid and our kids should be safe
and that's values and i think the values
of of america um i mean you know i have
conversations with you know both sides
and in the middle and there just seems
to be more reasonable civil discourse
with people on the right yeah so we we
had this event in new york just as on
saturday this one
the festival of ideas put on by
minds.com
and that that is the idea can we bring
together you know different factions
different people to come and talk about
these issues and the answer is no you
can't and i think the reason no you
can't is because the moral framework of
the two factions has become so at odds
with each other that
you can bring people together but they
cannot
well i should say this i think the left
can't understand the right but the right
can understand the left so i'll give you
the example of the challenge we had a
panel it was uh uh james o'keefe tulsi
gabbard ben burgess of jacobin he's a
socialist a writer i think he's a social
i don't but he writes for socialist
magazine and uh uh and i we're on this
panel
before the uh before the show like
literally minutes james confronts ben
burgess about a video edit saying that
he cut out this important piece and
challenged ben on it and ben berg's
response was i don't know he responds at
the time
when we were on stage we're supposed to
be talking about media manipulation and
i think ben perfectly exemplified the
divide
james o'keefe said in this video
x happened
and you omitted it
ben said
unions are important and good and if you
don't support unions you don't support
free speech
therefore james o'keefe exposing a union
was harmful to them and that means what
he was doing was bad and then now my
attitude was my response was that has
nothing to do with truth or journalism
you've started your argument from
from the point of an id from an
ideological point unions are good james
targeted unions james is bad
that's not journalism
uh the question is
is james telling the truth that was the
issue is he being deceptive or not
and the answer is no
you're just mad because he did something
damaging to your ideological cause this
is a writer for a major publication i
think jacob's fairly good they defend
free speech i can respect that but that
exemplified the problem perfectly the
corporate press the woke
like aoc said it doesn't matter if
you're factually correct it matters if
you're morally correct
that's the difference between us and
them and that's called ad hominem uh
it's a fallacy it's a it's a diplomatic
fallacy if you attack someone's
character that's called like if you make
a commodity well you you wear green and
everyone knows that's the ugliest color
which is right
not the person the character but this is
this is not that this is
james o'keefe said thing happened thing
is true ben said but thing is bad for
unions and unions are good therefore you
are bad and i i'm not that that's not ad
hominem that is like or your work is bad
your journalism is deceptive and wrong
because it's harming unions which are
important for the people yeah he
attacked his his work ethic
yeah no no well the point is
you're either saying
a dog jumps out a window and a
journalist will say dog jumped out a
window and an ideolog ideologue will say
the dog was thrown out the window by an
evil person
because that's the moral good to condemn
those who raised the dog in a system of
oppression that resulted in him jumping
out the window in fear yeah like no that
didn't happen someone the dog just
jumped i don't know there's a point you
made earlier i kind of want to seize on
for a moment here you mentioned that
conservatives know more about how the
left thinks than the left knows about
how the right thinks and this is a point
we've made a number of times i think
this has also been
verified by different studies where they
pulled people on the left and asked them
to describe conservative opinions ask
people on the right to do the same thing
one thing we don't talk about as much is
the fact that
left-wing people also don't understand
the way that people who they consider to
be their allies think they don't
understand the way the people who they
claim to represent think they literally
do not take the time to figure out what
anyone else in the world believes they
think they have all the world's problems
solved with their ideology so whenever
it comes to women
or the black community or
any other group that you know the
islamic community for whom they claim to
advocate
they're constantly pushing for ideas
that members of that group generally
don't like so i've said this before uh
on the blm website there was language
about abolishing the nuclear family
right and when you look at blm and when
you look at how
black and brown have been included on
the pride flag to include black lives
matter well when it comes to the
question of homosexuality according to
polling data the black community is more
conservative than the white community
right what about women well
they seem to think that for women
liberation means you know going into the
workplace having an only fans
stripping selling new pictures of
yourself this is not how most women
think and then when it comes to islam
they want to be able to lump islam into
a category with these other groups as if
islamic religious fundamentalists have
the same goals or interests as these
other groups my point is
they make zero effort to understand what
anyone else wants or what anyone else
thinks it's not just conservatives
they're complete solipsists there was a
in the uk i can remember the
neighborhood of the area the city there
was an lgbt curriculum in a classroom in
a muslim neighborhood so all of the
religious muslims came out protesting
and you actually had this video where
it's like a gay guy saying like i'm
doing this for you and they're like we
don't like you and we don't like what
you're doing
but these these leftists have created
this narrative where
they're the saviors of all these
different groups there was one thing
that happened where some tv show
depicted a female muslim character who
was gay yep and the muslim community
went was it not out like it was they
were in an uproar like this is offensive
to us it's like did you think that going
against their strong religious
conservative muslim values
would make them like you yeah well
exactly and so i think part of the
reason they would do that is to kind of
like
groom the western muslim community into
adopting more of their values i remember
when that happened i did a cartoon
poking fun at the idea and there were
actually a number of muslim people
because it was funny the whole idea
behind the cartoon was like the left
just seeing groups of people as
caricatures and so there were some jokes
in there about like islam and what the
left's doing but the feedback i got from
muslim people is that they really liked
it even though it was poking some fun
they're like poking fun at the ideas of
the stereotypes because they're so sick
and tired of the left claiming that
they're like their avatar or pawn you
know and represent them somehow like the
muslim community is like in any way
emblematic of what the left's goals are
like
oh we talked about a little bit before
the show greg i was mentioning to you
that i think they call it the left even
people that call themselves leftists
because they want to project this idea
that they're half of the conversation
when in fact it's a very small group of
without making too many generalizations
drugged out people that are on like
adderall and other amphetamines since
they were 12 or whatever i don't know
how many of them there are but a lot of
people are on those like suicide watch
type people and
they have a microphone so
everyone else they're inside this like
echo chamber house of fun mirrors and
they see around and they see all these
other deranged people and then they
think if they can if they can somehow
help the deranged people then they're
helping the entire system but it's just
they're just like scratching their own
backs and everyone else can see inside
it's a one-way system we can all see
them doing it at least most people that
are aware of the media and the
manipulation stuff that are watching
around that stuff can tell the the
transgender like cutting up a kid's
genitals when they're nine is probably
not very good for the kid have you have
you seen all these performative outrage
videos of a roe v wade
no i haven't seen any so there's uh
women like screaming like
and they're like punching pillows and
things like that
they're all very obviously performative
for two reasons
they've set up their camera pressed
record stood back and then started
screaming
so they planned it it wasn't a true
display of emotion it was just there's
one video where you see one woman like
banging a pillow on the ground and it
starts with a brief her looking at the
camera and then going someone's moving
the camera and filming her and then she
stops and then pauses for second looking
at the camera very clearly an edited
performance
people see that and say oh if i'm to fit
in i need to be angry about this they
don't know why they're angry they were
just told to be billy joe armstrong goes
on stage and he's like i'm renouncing my
citizenship because people are so stupid
and he's probably not gonna i would be
very surprised if he literally renounced
his citizenship it's a complicated
process i doubt he's gonna go to the
consulate and be like yes here's my
signature my official form of renunciate
renunciation and i would like to have a
meeting with the uh american consulate
officer to swear my like it's not
something you just do
so i really doubt he's gonna he's gonna
go back he's gonna smoke pot go like
what was i gonna do again
but when he goes on stage and says this
everyone's like yeah yeah i'm angry too
i don't know why but the guy on stage
said to be they see all the videos these
young women see the videos getting likes
so they make more videos like this to
get attention they don't actually know
what they're protesting they don't even
know what roe v wade did
they don't know why it was overturned so
they just say it's the handmaid's tale
get your bible out of my body and it's
like they didn't overturn us on any
religious grounds at all well part of
what part of what i think is well and
that's also because this is another
example of of the left not knowing how
anyone else thinks not knowing how to
frame an issue they think that this is
just a matter of like some small
minority religious fundamentalists who
want to ban abortion and that there are
no reasons outside of you know divine
revelation to want to oppose abortion
but also uh
they think that i think some of them
really seem to think that abortion has
been criminalized nationwide because of
this this is part of what's so funny
about um armstrong billy joe armstrong
yeah saying that he's going to renounce
his citizenship
many blue states are still going to have
abortion laws which are more lenient
than the ones in europe and in the uk
particularly yeah so he's going to be
moving to a country that probably has
stricter abortion laws than the state
he's fleeing and king well has a queen
yeah i know it's that's insane he can
move to colorado where there's zero
restrictions instead the uk the uk has
like a de facto abortion because the
women can be like my mental health is
affected and they'll give them the
abortion but you still need a process
whereas in colorado you don't and he's
complaining it's like dude
the states are like like how big is the
uk you know like com comparable to what
state oh that's a good question i
wouldn't hazard a guess but quite small
compared to uh
many of the states the united states and
all of europe are comparable in size
right so the uk
living there would be akin to him being
like i'm moving to colorado it's like a
different state it does it it's crazy
that
europe has no unified abortion law
similar to how the united states doesn't
and there's there's actually i think
finland i think it's banned outright
that could be wrong it's like heavily
restricted or something
i think most states most countries in
europe it's like 12 weeks at least and
they're they're they're decently
restricted in the united states up until
the overturning of roe the us was way
more lenient than europe
do you think it's it's similar to you
know with him just spouting this you
know
get behind this i haven't really you
know i don't have an opinion or a value
on it because anyway i'm not i'm a
birthing person uh who likes saying
women these days um you know it's like
it's like i saw during covid the new
diseased until proven healthy i call it
covert woke you know it's like
it's like cancel cultures guilty till
proven innocent it's let's just you know
let's let's chant the slogan and be part
of that crowd that is on the righteous
side without really just investigating
what well it is it is self-righteous
it's a bunch of people with pitchforks
and torches yeah and they're like i'm
just here to fit in
let's pull this picture we got here we
got a tweet from andrew doyle take a
look at this it's terrifying so um
greg you're from the uk right it's not
yes i am what what is this where is this
location it looks it looks like well
there's a double decker bus there it
looks like it's regent street looks like
south looking down region street which
crosses oxford street but it also looks
like um i don't know it's it's
emblematic somewhat of uh
for those for those are just listening
it is probably what like a hundred
like pride intersex flags
five five flags per row 10 flat 10 rows
at least 50.
well it cuts around the corner so you
can't actually see but you got one two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 that can be seen right so uh
quite a bit more than 50.
65 at the very least
yeah this is uh well i what i think
maybe you were thinking this greg i'm
not sure correct me if if i'm wrong but
this looks like i thought this could
have been a picture from nazi germany
that was colorized and then the flat the
nazi flags were superimposed with pride
flags
because it's the sa it is freaking
terrifying how a bunch of i don't want
no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
generalize ideological flags being flown
so i have a question though are is it
overreact is it is that an overreaction
because i was facetiously tweeting on
twitter like it's literally nazi germany
i don't care about the pride flags well
you know i look at what what i go ahead
just real quick i'm wondering if you've
ever seen an ideological flag flown to
this degree in the uk like this never
but
no and what what it makes me think about
is the union jack the flag of england so
it was about 15
16 years ago i went back to england and
you know i'd been away for a while
because i live in america american
citizen now and i mentioned flying the
union jack the flag of it and oh no you
can't do that you can't do that you you
it's a symbol of racism now i'm like
hang on a minute the union jack is a
symbol of race when did that happen you
know i grew up my gran my grandfather
fought in the second half so long ago oh
my grandfather but he did he fought in
the second world war you know and he
lost his firstborn son during the second
world war well yeah like
why can't we be patriotic why can't we
talk about you know the pride for the
people who give their lives and to to
afford us our freedoms and and i look at
this and i think well it's not so much
that flag it doesn't really really mean
that much to me it's what flag should be
flying there and if it were flying there
um what we would be thinking what we
would be told to be thinking you know we
well we can't celebrate that flag let's
let's read andrew doyle's tweets he said
for some these flags represent diversity
and inclusion but for many they
symbolize an ideological movement that
is hostile to gay people and women's
rights opposes free speech legitimizes
violence and bullying and hounds people
out of their jobs if they fail to
conform yeah that's right uh there was a
comic shop near me um a while ago and i
remember i went there and it was cool
and that stuff and i bought it one day i
came back and they had a big flag one of
these flags in there and i was like i'm
not gonna go there again because these
are the people that have defended murder
and violence
if i went to a comic shop and they had a
swastika flag i also would be like i'm
not gonna go there because these are
people who have justified violence
murder and harmed other people and i
don't trust people of this extremist
ideology
if i'm working if i if i'm if i'm on the
job and i'm working politically and i
have security and stuff i have no
problem interviewing antifa or alt-right
or whatever but i'm not going to go to
an establishment that flies that flag
because it's legitimately an extremist
organization
flying the flag of an extremist ideology
not interested you know going to new
york this past weekend for the event
every single business was flying the
flag
you come out to west virginia and
surprise surprise even small towns out
here fly these flags but these flags
they do not represent
pride
and love and inclusion
they are flown by people who have thrown
molotov cocktails through buildings they
are flown by people who have
brutally beaten journalists in the
street and who advocate for executions
assassinations and revolution they are
political extremists
now if you agree and bend the knee to
the ideology you'll be fine
but if you stand up defiantly and say
what you did to that man in provo utah i
think it was a man shot in the arm
driving his car for no reason is wrong
and they say it was for a good cause
what you did to david dorn was not good
they say don't you dare defy us it's
like okay these people are psychopaths
and the flag of a psychotic death cult
is being flown now you want to come out
and say that donald trump supporters are
a death cult and all that stuff and i'm
like dude
there is there's no institutional power
behind the q anon people none
maybe maybe some high profile people but
nothing relevant
in the in the modern conservative
movement libertarian and and with
moderates joining the ranks it's people
being like i think people should have a
right to choose in their own state how
they live
versus the left saying the federal
government should impose our will over
the entirety of the country one's
extremist
seeking politics based on domination and
the other is seeking politics based on
moderation
unfortunately it seems like the
moderation political side is going to
get crushed because they don't seek to
dominate their opponents
i think there are some people who who
maybe fly this flag and believe in
inclusion and believe that they're
believing it it's like a friend of mine
who
she was she was ultra woke and she was
on the women's march and now she's kind
of you know
she's come
she's broke through that belief system
let's say she doesn't have that uh that
ideology that's like everyone on that
side is bad and she's actually seen
behind the behind the curtain that you
know the mainstream media is not all
it's purporting to be and it is a lot of
propaganda so i think there's people
that do you think there are people who
are just ignorant who do you
want you know want to support because i
have nothing against the fly when i see
the flag i don't think bad things oh
well the swastika it was the wheel of
life it's the hindu
flower of life it's an ancient symbol of
peace and the turning of growth and
death and life and rebirth and it was a
beautiful symbol and the nazis believed
in the purity and the wonder of germany
it was that's what the people believed
in is the greatness of the fatherland
and then of course the psychopath drug
addict twisted it
yeah the guy was on meth
like crazy hitler
he was also deranged from the war he was
just a broken mentally broken and this
is the issue
uh i'm not i think people need to
understand too the refusal to see
historical analogs is based on the fact
that things haven't gotten that bad yet
that's that's insane
so when you have
nazi germany i i think it is a bit silly
to constantly use them as the example
but they were so egregious but why don't
we use communist uh russia and the
revolution and that's more akin to the
leftist revolution and they had their
flag and they had their symbol the
sickle and the hammer and they executed
the communism killed over 100 million
people
only lasted 60 soviet union only 69
years and look how much death
destruction and genocide they waged and
people flew their flags
people thought it was for the good for
the better they said it's we're fighting
for the work the workers and we're
making the world a better place and
we're dealing with the oppressors
and they were ruled by psychopaths the
average person who flew the flag
they're not evil they're stupid
but stupid people in large quantities
are extremely dangerous you know michael
malus talks about
he says how could anyone be blackpilled
these people are so incredibly stupid
and i somewhat agree with him but i will
point out zombies are also stupid and a
hundred thousand zombies marching
towards you is a force to be reckoned
with that's what we're dealing with
people flying this flag are just like i
don't know whatever
do as you're told don't don't
resist and you'll be fine you won't be
they'll still come for you and cancel
you no matter what you do there was that
author recently who made an off-color
joke or something had to apologize and
then even though he apologized they came
after him again that's the story
tales all this time
the people are flying these flags
because they think everyone else thinks
it's popular no one actually knows or
cares what it means it's a it's a
mishmash of nonsense
i'm willing to bet in fact when i was in
new york people were flying the rainbow
flag and that's considered offensive now
but they didn't know that so they were
just because the rainbow flags
considered defensive yes why is that
it's exclusionary to trans people and
black people see i mean there you go
it's like you know and now we see
martina navratilova's comment
you saw what she said to me what she uh
i said that um
given that there's a higher uh history
of mental illness among the left
and that trans people have a higher rate
of suicide red flag laws will be used
against them more often than against the
right and then she angrily responded
that i was an idiot that i was an a-hole
that i was making these things up and it
wasn't true
and i just it's crazy to me because she
sounds dangerous someone needs to well
the police need it i'm kidding it takes
you two seconds to just google it and
what do you get three thousand articles
all these different studies showing the
left has higher rates of mental illness
it's a fact
it is an established scientific fact
that the more liberal and left-leaning
you are the higher your rates of mental
illness
i didn't make that up
she was arrogant she was ignorant and
that's exactly the problem
she just saw what i said and said how
dare you i'm angry
that's it that happens a lot and to your
point about communism and the hammer and
sickle you know there are a lot of
people still we we do
you know the false glamour of our
idolatry and our iconography i mean we
think it's cool but we forget at times
uh that you know millions of people were
slaughtered uh you know during you know
these things
the holiday more yeah i mean so you know
i was suggesting that people shouldn't
be you know should people be glorifying
the hammer and sickle we don't glorify
the swastika i mean you know
that's that and that is something that
uh is a failure of our education
our culture and our institutions and now
our institutions are co-opted so they'll
never come out against it but the sickle
and hammer represents 100 150 million
dead
i mean the the things the systemic and
systematic execution of people
and what people were the people on the
left i love this the occupy wall street
people
they don't understand they're the
bourgeois the bourgeoisie
that does not mean the wealthy elites it
means the middle class and the
proletariat the workers
they don't realize they are the people
they are advocating for their own wealth
distribution redistribution or being
thrown in the gulags
yeah no it's true i've had that i've had
that conversation with people who are
very wealthy and consider themselves to
be on the left like no you don't like
you are the bourgeoisie no no it's not
extremely wealthy it's middle class
extremely wealthy compared to a large
pers like the vast majority of the world
population these these kids
these young people who are socialists
and they make 50 60 000 a year i'm like
you are exactly who marx wanted to get
rid of hmm
and stalin stalin's a better example
because he was the one who actually did
it
yeah they don't understand the
intelligentsia these people the laptop
class
when the if you were in russia i mean
that's who they came for first the
commune already has a buzzfeed article
writer um
yeah you you mentioned the fact that the
hammer and sickle is not as taboo and
it's funny because you'll see a lot of
lefties flying that flag or putting in
their bio as if that's edgy or
interesting but it's basically always
been allowed at least throughout my
lifetime the only way i remember
communism really being addressed was
with reference to the quote-unquote
overreaction from it in the united
states i even remember in history class
and in public school when they were
explaining communism to us of course
they mentioned that many people were
killed but they also talked about the
poor people who were supposedly helped
by it and we were kind of given both
sides there which is really interesting
can you imagine if a public school
teacher said well let's give you like
both sides of this whole nazi thing
right they did fix the economy and
mussolini made the trains run on time
yeah and so
yeah if i care about those things
exactly and so
i gotta say
it probably has something to do with the
fact that many people in uh media and in
academia are and have been communists
four decades yeah people are commenting
like mccarthy was right well and it's
funny because people people are shocked
when you say that it's like well why
would that not be the case
fear of communism has always always
always in every single instance that
shows up in media been scoffed at or
laughed at
it's just a moral panic why were people
afraid of that ideology that killed
hundreds of millions of people how silly
you made a funny comment earlier about
the feature dystopia and the flags of
the rainbows and stuff
oh was this when was this just a moment
ago oh my gosh yeah before the show
started no i was just saying like for
historians to look back on all the
tyrannical systems throughout all of
history and then they see ours and the
flag is like rainbows happy fun like all
of the other tyrannical regimes have
these very intimidating symbols and i
was like happy birthday the swastika was
a beautiful it wasn't intimidating in
the beginning it was the wheel of light
it was it was a beautiful symbol and
maybe it's it's because of the context
but also at the same time like a
swastika like that black symbol inside
of a white circle on a red flag does
look intimidating
so so this is an interesting point man
like
it's funny that you bring up the
rainbows and stuff
but uh
i went to an antique shop when i was in
texas and they had so many swastikas all
over the place
and this is in austin and i was like
it's trump's america you said yeah i was
like i was like hey hey ho ho antique
shop has got to go and no i'm kidding
but i asked him i was like hey how can
you all the swastika stuff and they said
in the early 1900s
it was considered a symbol of good luck
and healing and all these good things
that's why the nazis took it so
you could go around the u.s in on the
south side of chicago where i grew up
there's a house
that had a swastika it was a two-story
building a swastika on the top and wood
blocks were hammered in to make it a
square
but you could see it and you knew it was
a swastika i thought you were going to
say there's a swastika in the house and
my old argentinian neighbor insisted it
was just a peace symbol
you see it on like uh buildings in
downtown chicago too in the loop you'll
see like just carved into the stone
masonry swastikas all along the top
in 19 it wasn't until world war ii the
symbol became something else and they
inverted it the the actual symbol is
that in the mirror yeah that's right so
just think about that
everybody is putting up these good luck
symbols all over the place and then all
along comes nazi germany and it wasn't
until we learned of what they were doing
that we were like whoa that symbolized
all this really really bad stuff
so historians look back at it and
they're like look how evil and awful
this symbol is they'll they may do the
same exact thing to these flags they're
not going to look at it like it was it
was pretty and happy they're going to
look back and be like wow how evil and
disgusting who knows wasn't there the
party originally that was it the german
national socialist workers national
socialism
was a slur it was like they were making
fun of it and stuff yeah the german
workers party or whatever right yeah
yeah but they were like their their
version of socialism was based on like
race
so it was
like is it identitarianism it wasn't
really socialism some people want to say
it is but it's like it's like racial
identitarian economics is something
slightly different racial identitarian
socialists that sounds a little bit
familiar
and it's not even a joke that's true the
fear 100 percent
let me put it this way too sorry these
flags represent the exact same political
ideology as the nazis yep not
not in the sense of what they've done or
what to do
it it covers identitarianism yeah they
are identitarian flags that your race or
or uh
you know so it's a flag of
identitarianism now how they implement
it how they feel about certain races is
different but it's an identitarian flag
that's what i mean to say
i think that's what the nazi stood for
youtube keeps telling me to inject ads
they're like don't do it
with the healthy aging support of
collagen
another aspect that worries me as we
talk about the allegories between the
flags being flown ideologies being being
pushed is the the economy
flailing right now like it was in 1928
29 right before hitler
germany we keep saying that here we are
you tell me you're going to fix it you
tell me who the enemy is and i'm i'll
follow you anywhere because i'm starving
el salvador's looking pretty good right
about now well it's nev it was
inevitable that was going to happen with
the economy but i'm still surprised that
the alarm bells aren't really they don't
seem to be ringing in the press that
much it's like oh there's stuff they're
in on it the press is in on it that's
what
i don't have a paper trail but that is
certainly what it seems like is
happening have you uncovered much of a
paper trail what do you mean between
global economy and the u.s media
apparatus
cnn comcast do you mean like how jim
cramer was telling people to buy up
stocks right before the 08 crash or how
he's like continually telling to buy
when then the market crashed
again recently doing this
i think that's just in his blood isn't
it no
the the media sells you out and lies to
you the corporate press and the elites
along with it i mean come on
when i was on stage at the mines event i
wrapped up by saying
you know uh trayvon martin's story was
fabricated they nbc edited the audio to
make it seem like zimmerman was racist
michael brown hands up don't shoot that
wasn't true justice that wasn't true
russiagate ukraine gate
joe biden started his campaign the the
um the very fine people hoax like it's
all lies and it always props up the
establishment politicians and their
agenda what i like now and what i think
is different than 1929 is it was mass
media was new then they had radio and
they just began like television and
video or video and stuff uh film and so
they were they all bought in they
thought it was real even more of the
worlds that orson wellesley people some
people i've heard thought that it was we
were actually being attacked by aliens
people didn't question the media like
hitler had his minister of propaganda
and no one i mean people i don't think
really quit they just saw it they were
brainwashed now we know that it's
brainwashing and so we're at least aware
and so i think that's why there's so
much pushback like what you're saying
earlier about glenn young and getting
elected people being able to see the the
manipulation a lot more effectively than
a hundred years ago all right let's
let's let's talk about the nightmare
dystopia we are in because we're in one
you know we talk about these flags being
flown and we're like well you know maybe
it means this and maybe they'll say this
in the future
i give you this tweet from the readout
companies covering some or all travel
cost for abortions
we've got city yelp bumble levi's lyft
apple amazon starbucks zillow airbnb
paypal disney bank of america mastercard
tesla metamicrosoft dicks patagonia
jpmorgan match doordash netflix and
reddit
just some of the companies that are
covering the cost of abortion for their
female employees for one reason
maternity leave costs more money welcome
to the corporate nightmare dystopia
you've long been warned about personally
i never thought
paying for women to kill their children
because it's cheaper than paying for
maternity leave would become a left-wing
position but here we are i want to add
we here at timcast will not
be paying the costs for any of our
employees to travel to and seek out
abortions we do however offer unlimited
maternity and paternity leave because we
trust those who are going to have to
raise their family to spend as much time
as they need and then they can come back
when they see fit all they got to do is
let us know and we will try and figure
out how to fill in because family comes
first and if every business worked that
way maternity leave paternity leave and
family comes first we have a very strong
robust healthy society but unfortunately
corporations today
are saying look it's going to cost us
four to five grand in maternity leave
and then you got paternity leave on top
oh that's a new thing and i just give
her the two grand for the abortion and
get rid of it well also she's going to
be working fewer hours most likely she
could because she's going to be more
focused on being a mother taking care of
her child and oh my goodness it might
even be the case that she stops working
all together to be a stay-at-home mom
and then you have to find somebody else
so it's cynical it's evil they would
literally rather slaughter infants than
see any decline in their profits and of
course the left has a blind spot here
the left has a very obvious blind spot
here because they see abortion as
utility which allows them
consequence-free sexual access to
women's bodies without any potential
responsibility being incurred as a
result and so they're completely willing
to support this horrific dystopian
garbage
because if they didn't they would have
to come to terms with how twisted and
broken their world view is and they
would also
heavens forbid
have to live in a society where they
need to control their sexual urges
instead of doing whatever they want
whenever they want and that's ultimately
what this is all about
it's all about short-term pleasure and
short-term i gotta be honest like
it's not even about that because iuds
exist and condoms exist
it's like you don't have to control your
urges you just want to argue well that's
the thing one argument that they make is
well what if this fails and so there was
a there was an interesting analysis from
the brookings institute which came out
where they were looking uh at the
explosion in fatherlessness in the black
community and one argument they made is
it was actually the
legalization and increased legalization
of abortion prior to roe v wade and then
abortion being legalized nationally
after roe v wade which led to the
collapse of the black family because it
broke down the expectations that you
should be with someone who you would
have kids with greg what do you think
about the corporations oh i think we
have said this before we're living in an
era of woke capitalism in which
companies pretend to care about social
justice to sell products to people who
pretend to hate capitalism and i think
that really you know just
there's money in it there's money in
virtue signaling there's money in foe
glamour and foe communism and we're
against the and i i just i i'm just
sometimes
frankly appalled at um
the hatred the the visceral hatred
towards this amazing country that i came
to 28 29 years ago and afforded me um
great opportunities and it's it's an am
i wish we could talk more about what we
love
as much as what we hate and
i think the the the wokification um of
america is just tragic in so many
respects it's just so amazing i wonder
how many these companies
when they saw the roe v weight decision
they probably went yeah baby because now
we can justify not paying eternity to
leave yeah kaching yeah how creepy is
this it's like every nightmare corporate
i just i just it's just i'm speechless
yeah it's disgusting i mean but this is
also part of what happens when you have
a society which restructures itself and
reorients itself away from being about
virtue and character development and
towards short-term gratification
ultimately that's what abortion is is
the ultimate example of saying all that
matters is convenience i don't care who
has to get hurt as long as i'm not
forced to take upon any responsibility i
got an idea for you seamus for a cartoon
it's a corporate psa from one of these
companies and they're like we here at
apple care deeply about our employees
that's why as an employee here if you
ever encounter an unwanted pregnancy we
will cover your cost to seek an abortion
and the man goes what about maternity no
well and so this is funny right the left
says we need abortion because we need to
guarantee a woman's right to choose but
then whenever they look at anything else
that happens in the corporate world
between an employer and their employee
they say this is a totally coercive
relationship people don't really have
the ability uh to choose new jobs so
this is i mean by their analysis this is
against women's choice because you
literally have employers economically
incentivizing women to kill their unborn
children amazing
another another idea for a bit would be
like a woman going into her supervisor
and being like i think i'm pregnant and
i may need maternity to leave and he
goes
have you considered aborting it and
she's like no i can't afford it we got
you covered
the uh you guys follow that robert reich
is it reich or reich anyone anyone know
for sure whichever one's the bad one
yeah yeah
and he tweeted out i guess
uh july
2021 let's get one thing straight
freedom doesn't mean you have the right
to recklessly endanger others by
refusing to get vaccinated i saw that
and then from like today or yesterday
tweets out i don't know who needs to
hear this but every every person should
have control over their own body so he
doesn't know who needs to hear it
because it's him a year ago
you don't have the right to refuse to
get vaccinated and then yesterday he
said you should have control over your
own body
i don't understand where the disconnect
is
well it's my body my choice until it
actually you know uh it's well it's like
you know it's there's difference when
it's covered and when it's when it's the
book
there isn't any logic you know it's it's
not hypocrisy
whatever benefits them is good period
yeah well yeah yeah i mean i i actually
you know i was flying here and i saw
people still wearing masks i don't think
people are afraid of coven anymore
they're afraid of of others knowing i
think what what coveted revealed about
themselves and you know that whole that
whole situation that two years
of plus of covert to me was i mean i
called it right at the start the panic
demik not the pandemic um you know the
the
there was this this sense of
um you know taking away our rights
and if we let them take away our rights
during emergencies they're going to
continue to manufacture emergencies to
take away our rights and i you know to
me i'm i'm british i didn't grow up here
but i see this lack of people
actually getting it like
the freedom of speech is one another
thing i see in the uk they have hate
speech laws there are the police forces
are trolling the internet and arresting
knocking on people's doors and pulling
them in and and and and charging them
with crimes for things they've said yeah
i mean like freedom of expression like
you know as long as there's no enzymes
if device say what you want
you know you don't have to agree um but
it's it's it is dystopia i mean you
called it it's this dystopia that people
just seemed many people don't see once
again and it's with and these are all
the companies that change their their
twitter avatars to rainbow flags
like they don't they don't care about
you
they're gutting the system so there was
uh in new york city and san francisco
there were stampedes at their pride
events
um i think in new york someone let off
fireworks i'm not sure it might have
been both places and then people
stampeded out screaming and thinking
there was a shooting
i was looking at these photos and these
videos of this stuff and i'm just like
at some point they i don't know if they
ever were
about
celebrating love
it's you look at the videos you don't
think ever
i don't know if ever not in my life
right not in my lifetime yeah my my
family owned a cafe on the north side of
chicago and i wasn't allowed to go
outside during pride
because it's debauchery
it's nude people doing things to each
other and just like things children
shouldn't see
and so my mom would be like hey pride is
this weekend don't go outside and we're
gonna you know just keep him in the back
don't let him see and then i remember i
had to go out one time and and i saw it
i was a little kid nude women nude men
doing things inappropriate around
children people dancing around skipping
through the street naked there's viral
videos going around right now of a man
wearing a bug's bunny mask totally naked
dancing jumping through the street i saw
that and i'm 54 and i don't want to see
that there's a video of an old man with
a big gut and tidy white he's twerking
in front of like children
and it's like that's not about love it's
just not about love and being proud
parents taking their kids out to see
just the same people who saluted uh uh
you know whichever corrupt ideology be
it the red salute or otherwise i i have
family members and friends that i i
couldn't believe it a few years ago
seeing a march the street do the red
salute
they're like oh it just means black
power and i'm like and the and the roman
salute meant white power you're doing an
identitarian salute to a fascist or
authoritarian regime like i don't care
what you think you're doing you're
you're in a death cult and you've lost
your mind there was a march in in i
think the uk a couple of weekends ago
maybe last weekend
and uh and the chant was ho chi minh
chai guevara style and ochi mensch and
i'm thinking what are you doing what are
you doing
what are you you're walking through this
and i think they're just blindly
chanting catch phrases and you know
going back to communism and with no
understanding of history but then it's
no surprise given the educational system
given the fact that we're burning books
and we're knocking down statues and
we're not learning any lessons from
history or we're not relearning the
lessons from history that they taught us
and history tours it does it doesn't
matter what we know from history that's
the sad reality we watched them tear
down the statues we knew what would
happen when they did we learned the
lessons from 1984 they were renaming
streets that's one of the lessons and we
watched them do it in new york they
illegally painted black lives matter in
front of trump tower seizing taxpayer
dollars to do it and corrupt police
officers blindly and stupidly defended
it and arrested those who challenged it
the governments in these cities have
become overtly corrupt the institutions
are overtly corrupt we are watching it
happen and we know exactly what it means
in the turn of a century
when people are tearing down statues
and replacing them with idea with with
their own ideology and not being held
accountable the next steps are obvious
if we stay on a comparable track to the
1900s
and everyone knows it i know it sheamus
knows it you know it people have talked
about it ad nauseam the tearing down of
statues the renaming of streets 1984 is
here merrick garland rejecting the
ruling from the supreme court the doj
arresting republicans the front-runner
in in michigan was arrested
we have a former trump senior doj
official jeffrey clark raided by the fbi
james o'keefe a news organization
admittedly according to the fbi raided
by the feds the federal government has
been weaponized and is going after
people who oppose their ideology they've
been tearing down statues and doing all
the corrupt things we expect and that's
it we know it's happening so what next
what is next mean what do so people
listening to this award you're gonna go
well what do i do what can i do
there's a possibility right now that um
in november the republicans win
and that's the big question if here's
what i fear
if the republicans win and then do
nothing
this this country is already collapsed
if the republicans win and then we see
investigations we see subpoenas
that could be pulling pulling us out of
the tailspin and correcting the
corruption of the biden administration
of joe biden himself the things his son
has done if those are investigated if
the summer of love riots are
investigated if the 529 insurrection is
investigated perhaps that could
lead to an uprighting
and and pulling this country back
together do you think there's an
argument for the for the
converse of that yes i've just like
let's just move forward and not go back
and forth between impeach them
impeachment no if the republicans do
nothing then the country implodes
because uh if you if
i've been doing a lot of reading about
the civil war
and one of the principal issues was that
the south felt the federal government
was not enforcing laws that harmed it
the north was getting to do whatever
they wanted and that's comparable to
what we're seeing now with antifa
killing you know anti-fun blm writing
and the summer of love and 30 plus
people being murdered dying david dorn
being shot in the chest kamala harris
fund-raised for these people joe biden's
staff donated to bail these people out
but outside of that you have trump
officials being raided by the feds you
have republicans like in nevada the
chairman having their phone records
seized the federal government has been
weaponized against their rival political
party if nothing happens you're going to
see this country get ripped apart what's
what i think is likely to happen is
like texas it's already happening
actually missouri says they're they're a
sanctuary to federal gun laws new
hampshire just declared the same thing
california declared on immigration
they're ripping themselves apart from
the from the federal government saying
you have no authority here on these
issues anymore well it's not it's not
overt nullification they're saying we
don't recognize those laws and we will
not be party to any to assistance in
enforcement of them
that's step one
what happens now you've got all these
states saying we ban official travel
between these states for these things
they support the country is hyper
polarizing geographically that's a
precursor to outright statewide conflict
interstate uh conflict
i think if republicans get in
and actually do something
it will be tumultuous but maybe start
correcting the problems in this country
and restoring accountability if the
republicans do nothing confidence is
lost and without confidence people
ignore the system outright you see this
in uh i saw this in sweden
a lot of people were saying the crime
was being committed by refugees it's not
true the crime was being committed by
the children of refugees people who were
born in sweden but were considered by
swedes to be immigrants
so what happens is you have these areas
like rinkaby in sweden
a bunch of somali refugees move into the
90s sweden says we don't care
they form an enclave they don't interact
with the outside government
today their children who have never been
a part of the system will throw bricks
at cops because they don't see the cops
as having any real authority and the
cops know it
that leads to total destabilization if
you get to the point in the united
states where people view the government
as illegitimate like aoc said the
supreme court's illegitimate several
other you know federal level politicians
have said this garland
the attorney general rejected the
supreme court ruling and said we're
going to resist this and we're going to
ensure these things stay
the country at the highest level
officially is being ripped apart
if that continues you will have people
in texas saying we don't recognize the
federal government at all and they'll
completely ignore it already starting to
happen texas legally allows for
suppressors manufactured in texas to be
used in texas without going through the
nfa stamping process which is a federal
law it's all it's already begun
it can change if confidence is restored
there's a possibility that if
republicans get in and start doing
things the left reacts so violently that
it's inevitable
i don't know for sure
i can only tell you if you read history
read read the history of the spanish
civil war read the history of the the
bolsheviks and and russia you look at
what's happening now and i don't see how
you can imagine this results in a
peaceful process i just don't see it
[Music]
so who's going to be the savior who's
going to be the
who would you see as the next president
to replace teleprompter president biden
i don't think it's donald trump i don't
think that the savior isn't the way it's
gonna that's what people think is that
someone's gonna sweep in and fix it but
it's about confidence and it's for the
people this this government was built by
us for ourselves and that we are running
it and we have people representing us at
the moment which can be recalled but
it's confidence in ourselves in myself
if i have confidence that my thoughts
and actions are going to contribute to
the betterment of society then maybe we
can write a new government maybe we can
evolve our constitution do you think
people have lack lacking confidence
because they've they've realized like i
referenced before the democratic primary
right for me there were i i came out and
supported andrew yang and i think there
were only two candidates who weren't
rife with identity politics and that was
tossy gabbard and andrew yang but it was
decided by that by the dnc so does the
vote like
people i think do you think people are
just disaffected going you know what it
doesn't matter what
i'll vote but it's gonna be decided by
people higher up trump winning in 2016
is proof that does matter you just need
that title force
you need people in a mass wave to go out
and vote to just overrun it we also need
to d uh to basically open up the
software code for whatever kind of
voting machines we use like dominion has
a proprietary
uh software and they they tally votes in
secret and we don't know what the
algorithm is doing we just assume
hopefully it's right but we don't know
and that's the problem we got to know we
got to see the machines in action if we
want to restore confidence in the system
then the public should own the voting
machines and the source code should be
open available to the public
and how do you change that if
you do it corporate so look
if republicans win in november
they i think we will see some stuff
happen because there's enough like the
freedom caucus is pretty good the
republicans who pretty much
they're doing good
uh in in terms of challenging the
establishment i'm not saying that to say
that all of their political ideology is
good but they're really sticking it to
the establishment
if they hold out
until 2024
and donald trump wins
it could be chaotic it will probably be
tumultuous but it could be
what we need to see accountability
i like desantis but i don't think he
would clean house and hold people to
account the way trump would because
trump's been slighted so heavily i think
trump wants revenge
but that could mean
do you think that's good
yes
really to have someone who's
fully motivated by revenge absolutely
really donald trump promised to drain
the swamp and then he didn't why because
he wasn't motivated by revenge he said
hillary clinton should be investigated
for her emails because she destroyed
something like 30 000 public records
and then he even said on stage she goes
well it's a good thing you're not
president and he goes yeah because you'd
be in jail then he gets elected he goes
i'm not going to pursue hillary clinton
because he wasn't motivated by revenge
he was motivated by okay look i'm
president let me clean things up we
didn't realize is that behind the scenes
these people were plotting to destroy
him and we got the russiagate hoax the
ukraine gate hoax and because trump set
back thinking they would play fair he
got bounced around smacked around and
then defeated if trump comes back in
he's going to be like i'm not falling
for that again you're fired you're fired
you're fired you're fired get out and
he's going to fire all of these trash
administrative state officials the
people who get hired in the intelligence
agencies who never get elected who never
rotate they're there for 20 years and
they dictate what the office does he's
going to walk in and say everyone out
i'm done
i don't think desantis would do that
that's why i think
there's there's pros and cons desantis
he's really good
he's a fighter he's young he speaks
better he's got more tact he's got
military experience he's got legal
experience all of that's really really
great
and maybe that is you know i i'm kind of
like you know between the two of them i
think we'll be good
i just think what we what would probably
be a little bit better
someone coming in and cleaning house and
if donald trump came in office and said
listen everyone's fired you're fired
you're fired you're fired you're fired
you're fired you crossed me you crossed
the american people i'll give you an
example did you know that donald trump
was trying to withdraw our troops from
syria and a ranking official lied to him
and the american people so that we could
keep troops in syria without the
american people or the president knowing
the commander-in-chief duly elected said
get our troops out he goes don't worry
we got him all out and he goes okay
and it was a lie
that's the kind of bs game they play so
if donald trump got elected and all he
did was say you're fired you're fired
everyone's fired and then he went i
resign i'd be standing ovation if that's
all he did
uh if he got the economy back on track
like he did in 2018 and 2019 then i'd
just be like all right you know i'll
take it and then we can have ron
desantis for somebody else
and vp
i don't know he's going to have his vp i
don't i don't know if desantis would do
it some people have suggested ron
desantis like a trump desantis ticket is
like that's a that's a power ticket i
mean that's victory right there but
desantis is too much of an alpha i mean
he's he's a good leader
i don't see him as a vp
i i see him as a president and i don't
know if he's going to want to be a vp
some say he can be trump's vp for one
term then run and win and get you know
two more presidential terms and that
would be really great for us so maybe
that's what should happen
i don't know though i don't know well
the vp is at a massively alpha position
it's just not the same alpha as the
president and there will be situations
where the president can overreally be
you're the president of the senate
basically if you're right that's true
yeah desantis as president of the senate
is huge tie breaker and all that stuff
yeah i don't know for sure man um
one thing i will say is
part of me just would prefer desantis
because of
he's just better across the board in my
opinion
but i don't know if he's gonna go in and
fire the people who need to be fired
that scares me because they'll screw
they'll screw him over the same way they
did trump if he's not careful
but trump is just going to go and be
like get out desantis just watched trump
get railroaded by what is essentially a
permanent state so i don't think that he
would be walking into it with his eyes
shut by any means i think that he's hard
enough he's hard as nails that man is
legit um i think he would be i think he
would be able to walk in and say you
know what you're all fired every single
one of you all the aids all the
assistants get out i want no one left in
this
white house whatever region he's talking
about i want nothing left you know that
might be bad because remember in iraq
when they when when they when my own
country invaded that country and
destroyed the bath party saddam's
political party they basically fired
them all
and then they became al-qaeda
uh
and correct me if i'm wrong maybe it was
the taliban but what happened i got them
mixed up because the media is like and
then there's isis oh another one uh but
what happened was they fired all these
political
state officials administrative state and
then they became a terrorist
organization that worked like
a co a covert government and that's what
if we went in and fired ever their
people or they're like us you know
they're sitting there they need a
paycheck they have families so where
would people who were fired from the
white house go i think i know exactly
where they would go they would go into
the media and i don't think the media is
possible
it's possible for it to be any more
compromised than it already is yeah
that's what they do right like the
intelligence agents like get jobs at
msnbc and cnn but so what their ratings
are in the gutter they can you know you
know what i'd love to see
it's like you know five years after
trump is president or whatever and you
go to you go to see a movie like you
know avengers
new avengers and you're like really
excited and they're standing behind the
counter there's like a bunch of dod
officials and they're like would you
like butter on your popcorn sir
yeah yeah please put butter on my
popcorn milly
i think the job economy is um
redundant maybe not redundant this is
the this is a federal reserve doctrine
to make sure that everyone has a job
they want people doing stuff so like
they want one guy to dig a hole then the
other guy to go fill the hole back up
and then they're gonna print some fake
money and then give people fake money
that they're gonna have to pay them back
at interest so the fed makes out the
federal reserve but they've just got
people busy and it doesn't mean just
because
we don't have to be doing jobs like
stuff has to get done but it doesn't the
idea that everyone has to have a job is
kind of
has to be redefined
well i don't i don't i don't agree
uh
people have to provide a service to
other people in exchange for
for goods produce like momentum of some
sort whether that's your own body heat
but this is this is like metaverse this
is like world economic forum stuff they
talk about extra extracting the heat
from your piezoelectric force like
getting the human body vibrating and
they're catching the electricity from
the vibration and they really like they
call them a useless class of people what
are we gonna do with these useless
people this is uh you've all know harari
talks about this
they really think that you know bodies
and vats you know and so greta tunberg
is wrong
she says there cannot be endless
economic growth because she doesn't know
what the metaverse is
in digital spaces i was playing this
game on my phone where it's like you
have a little golf ball and you like
pull back to like
change the strength and you try and punt
it into like a little hole or whatever
golfing with friends fun game is that
what it's called no no there's one on
steve no i don't know i was like you
know you're burning it goes in and then
you're like yeah i got a hole in one and
uh you can buy power-ups you can buy
different color golf balls
there's nothing happening when i buy
that golf ball for two bucks it's just
like
a piece of code says make it orange
but someone got two bucks for it there
can be endless economic growth that
doesn't destroy the country through
virtual spaces that's easy
like if you ever played world of
warcraft or any other online video game
and you sold the weapon to somebody or
something you're like yeah i'll trade it
to you here's 20 bucks in a way the job
economy is kind of the way that the
federal reserve bank for international
settlements
you know system is making people making
sure people aren't going crazy they want
them on the grid they want them on paper
to see like well they're still playing
our game they're still not
attempting to subvert us
but
they don't have to be doing it they just
want to make sure that they're there and
they're they're able to see them
the times they are changing i don't know
man they are i mean i you know when you
mention uh greta that was very good by
the way they're great i dare you i'll
tell you i mean i think to myself there
is there are actual experts who know
about climate and why aren't we
listening to them
but
you know are you familiar with graphene
here we go you can withdraw it from the
atmosphere from the carbon dioxide they
say there's too much carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere and there's too much
methane you can get it from methane too
you deposit it onto palladium and then
you
you extract the carbon and then you have
pure
graphene powder which is basically right
here basically you can mine the air and
you can reduce carbon emissions and turn
it into graphene and then use it as
building materials that's
blatantly obvious but we need more
people talking about in government right
yeah but it doesn't serve their interest
there's a meme going on nuclear power
and you know i mean just look at energy
i mean i've been talking with farmers
recently and people in the midwest and
you know
they're struggling like really
struggling not oh my god i'm only going
to be able to get three vanilla lattes
this week instead of two you know it's
like they're really struggling but th
the elite liberals do they just don't
seem to give
a rat's ass i'm allowed to say rat's
arse you shouldn't say ass
oh yeah okay good um yeah it was like
batting batting uh ambidextrously wasn't
calling is that a cricket reference or a
baseball reference it was baseball
i never played qriket before have you
gone for cricket i have i played when i
was younger and then revisited recently
when i was in india you know swelling
yes sheamus plays stickball
that's right tell us about that sheamus
i i don't even know what that is say
something witty about sticking things
there's just nothing i know i'm sorry
you guys want to play stickball you guys
want to go right hey let's go to super
chats you guys want to go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com to become a
member in the top right of the screen a
little sign up button we're gonna have a
members only show coming up at about 11
p.m tonight you don't want to miss it we
do that monday through thursday let's
read what y'all have to say
all right dr rollergator he says hi greg
you're the best
there you go you're the best thank you
dr rollergater i hope you're back on
twitter he got banned from
twitter yeah well maybe once elon gets
in it'll be like you know that scene in
avengers when they open all the portals
and everyone comes out to fight thanos
elon's voting republican apparently i
know i know oh he's gonna get can has he
been cancelled yet he hasn't tweeted in
a week
oh wow they're trying hard
could you be put in twitter jail
maybe
anyway technically yeah all right let's
see john kersten says tim great showing
against ben bergus when a high school
dropout intellectual
uh intellectual destroys a so-called
professor of physiolog of physiology
philosophy
uh he's a professor of philosophy not
physiology
and do you mean intellectually destroys
or a high school dropout intellectual
i'm not sure but i get what you're
saying i appreciate it
yeah that was great um he's referring to
i mean
i'll just put it this way
um i'm glad we did the event and i'm
glad ben was there
ben perfectly exemplified the corporate
press versus the independent media in
that his position was my ideology is
good therefore your reporting harms that
meaning you're reporting bad
whereas james and i are both like is x
true
very big difference and very easy for
people to understand so i appreciate him
going there because i'm sure he thinks
he's right and that's fine and i'm sure
many people agree with him and i'm sure
there are many people who can see
exactly what the point james and i are
trying to make
is a thing true does it rel it's not
relevant to the ideologues is he saying
is he saying it doesn't matter if x is
true because you're coming from a place
of w or or p that doesn't come before x
like you just doesn't matter framework
is wrong it doesn't matter if what
you're saying is true because you made a
video attacking unions and your goal was
to hurt my ideology okay
and my attitude is like is x true i
don't care about your ideology and
james's attitude is like is a thing true
i feel like james is very just
anti-establishment and and
anti-authoritarian and so when the
establishment is dominated by the left
they assume that he must be a
conservative he's probably a
conservative but um
like going after google and facebook i'm
like are those are those left-wing
organizations
yes apparently so well then so be it the
nice thing is though is he tends to i
don't think he doesn't really go after
stuff as much as people come to him when
something crazy happens yeah like the
amy rorbecks at the epstein stuff he's
like was that a conservative thing he
just did a sting operation on a
republican
and i'm like do any of these lefties
know that he just secretly recorded in a
republican you know field campaign
office or something like
whatever i'd like to get ben and james
together to follow up on that
i'm not sure that will happen maybe not
but it would be nice because i thought
it was rushed ben was kind of you know
wasn't expecting the conversation and
it'd be cool to go deeper all right
thick homidog says tim next time you're
in austin schedule with drinking bros
your episode with dan was great and many
of their listeners would subscribe to
you too
next time in austin if it's on the
weekend because i work all weekdays
cliff lee says at the mines event i was
sitting in front of the guy screaming
fire tim poole was he was someone
screaming that i don't know and i have
the whole video from zimmerman i can
show it to you right now said he works
for vox asked him to show me the video
he declined
i didn't hear anybody yell anything like
that so it was at a different panel he
was very confused no i'm kidding it
probably was because i don't think
anybody yelled like
we can't hear him fire tim fire him from
walking yeah
there's a comma there you know fire tim
you know i thought you can't heal fire
in a crowded theater it's like the um
apparently
the whole time remember the lionel hutz
uh simpson's joke that's right what did
the card say it was like let me look
that up yeah look up that one was really
funny but he drew in the commas to
change what it said it was it was it was
a good moment yeah um did you find it it
says
works on contingency no money down and
then aft it's works on contingency
question mark no
money down
no
question mark this guy didn't have the
punctuation in there
all right
kennedy anarchist says tim regarding
your plan to launch small shows for the
tim cast banner this youtube channel i
found called the meaning of nerd his
stuff is really good and i think you'll
like him for his uh for this idea of
yours
i think he even made a video on your
song once i think i did see that it was
very good we'll check it out
all right contrary says hey tim hope
you're well wanted to say you should
invite comedian christopher titus and
his crew i feel you both could get into
some good debate
um
i mean we could
there's a challenge i i feel like
i could be wrong about this but isn't he
just like um
just virtue signaling on twitter like he
doesn't really know what he's talking
about yeah that's twitter i don't know
if he is or not no i mean like there are
some people who make an argument left or
right and then there's some comedians
and celebrities who just post
regurgitated nonsense very tds yeah so i
don't know if like yeah but let's not
let twitter stop us from communicating
with
him argue with stephen crowder he's not
a nice guy oh okay well i don't like
i've seen his show in the 90s and i
thought it was relatively interesting
didn't he get like one season that was
canceled yeah probably titus it was
called i haven't heard his name since
the 90s
yeah or a couple times
all right brian david says is there a
practical difference between maximilian
robespierre and karl marx
i mean karl marx was like a spoiled
racist rich kid rich kid who was like
writing his you know ideology and
robespierre was like i want to kill
everybody so not at first at first he
was the man of the people all about
freedom and down with the monarchy and
we're going to change this for the
better is a lawyer
everyone who tells you they're like a
man of the people and love humanity is
uh he went that's about that
you guys got to look into robespierre he
was the the downfall the both the
inception and the downfall of the french
revolution i think it's uh a line from
dostoyevsky but he says something like
the more i love humanity the more i love
man as a whole the less i care for him
as an individual something like that no
it's like that's exactly how these
people are i love humanity in the
abstract but they treat everyone around
them horribly and they're fine
quote-unquote cracking a few eggs to
make the omelet right nick v says can
you touch upon the nude men exposing
themselves at pride parades around the
country this month this month have you
ever been to a pride event this has been
going on my entire life i've been a
bunch i was i fundraised for
organizations at pride events yeah
that's a common occurrence i'm talking
about it's not a dystopia this is just
reality it's always been like this now
it's televised as long as i've been
alive these events have always included
overt sex acts i i should say like i've
never seen people performing activities
at each other they've simulated them so
i should say simulated did you see the
guy with the big
penis head
i didn't know i saw the naked guy with
the with the sock on his parts and his
uh
is john thomas as we call it from
wherever i used to go gay pride
occasionally in in west hollywood and
you know
yes there was all that going i remember
seeing kids that's that's the don't
remember something i don't remember
seeing kids but that might have just
been my my lens not you know but
recently i mean there's a lot of kids
there it seems to be more that way yeah
you know and and it's not you know i
worry for you know there are certain
things that our kids shouldn't be
you know but then again you know who
is it up to me or is it up to the parent
of the kids you know and ultimately is
oh yeah look agreed
the issue is that as a culture we've
lost any sense of direction and parents
don't care about what their kids are
being exposed to and there's no values
so and those that do care don't get i
mean you look at loudoun county i mean
those that duke i don't really have a
say and they've found out what's what's
what their kids have been taught and
it's
not good
you know the education system is pretty
flawed i would say
here in the united states of america
which i love but you know um yeah the
public schooling system is just built to
make factory workers for the most part
oh i mean i mean so i think it was six
seven years ago phenomenological based
learning was introduced in finland you
know the world leader in education and
then a couple of years ago they
introduced critical thinking into the
the the curriculum rather than critical
race theory it's like let's teach our
kids how how to critically think and
let's teach our kids how to think not
tell them what to think you know that's
important yeah
you made the point you mentioned that
you you know felt it was maybe a little
ironic that you love this country and
hate the educational system i think
that's perfectly consistent our system
is downright un-american and ironically
enough
all the values and promotes are like
totally antithetical to what this
country is supposed to be about what
it's supposed to mean it was built
around the time they established the
federal reserve the the the bankers and
you know investitures
we've got tony seki is saying what do
you think of the leaked project veritas
audio of sc senate candidate crystal
matthews chris crystal or crystal i
think it's crystal crystal it's spelled
like crystal matthew's calling for drug
money far left sleepers and fraud do you
guys see this one yeah i'm just like
dude we're
crazy she's she's a leaked audio where
she's calling someone saying they need
sleepers in the republican party to
destroy them oh yes yeah
yeah that's who was she the girl that
was calling senate candidate senate
yeah
yeah
they were asking
she said that but she also said like you
know basically i don't care you know and
anyway i'm not going to say what she
said because
you can check it out people can find it
last time last time they asked for a
sleeper they got joe biden
am i right
do you know that tim does a great
captain sparrow impression i didn't know
that
i did not have the idea he's saying you
drink too much oh wow
tim i want to hear it from you i
actually drank
i had i think an ounce of champagne
oh no no no no i had a glass
because we were filming
it all starts with that little white lie
yeah white lie
right saying i drink just starts with
one just first it was a little bit now
it's a whole glass now it's a whole
glass
well i mean like you know two bottles
there's like a couple bottles i just
chugged on them it was no i had like a
glass i i had like uh like a glass i
would say a full glass we were filming a
thing where we had to like party it was
fun
you were filming and you were drinking
alcohol yeah we had a limo and there was
champagne in the limo so we were filming
and we'd like crack it open and pour it
because ordinarily when we film we film
with you know it's not and it's alcohol
we wouldn't drink alcohol but you saw
that as an opportunity to be method you
were a method actor well i mean we
didn't have any fake booze in there okay
fair enough the crazy thing is we got a
limo had bud light
it's like 9am and sheamus was like i'll
have a beer at 9am and i was like
sheamus alice well allison and i were
like this is insane that there's alcohol
in a moving vehicle like when are you
ever going to have that opportunity to
be like oh we'll have a sip of a moving
vehicle and then seamus was like we're
degenerates and then i was like this is
the worst thing i've ever thought
9 a.m it was kind of crazy though
also it's like look i know that tim
spent a lot on this limo we gotta take
advantage of money the beer cost extra
shame exactly
well if you would have told me that tim
wouldn't have had any
all right let's see
nick s says tim you broke your wrist
demanding pictures of spider-man didn't
you uh
carter did what's called a misty flip
into our new air bag
it's a front flip and a 180. so we like
front flips and then lands going
backwards and then i went up behind him
and just did a like a basic drum but
then i slipped out and fell and busted
both of my wrists can you see the palm
of my hand oh yeah
it's all red
well no no all the red scrapes oh okay
yeah and then i've got like it's like
bleeding did you get the fall on video
no dang boop yeah my brother was filming
and he filmed carter do the front flip
180 and then i was like i just went up
and went around i was doing a just jump
in the gap
and then i slammed and i was like well
at least did you get it he was like i
don't know i wasn't filming it got it
filled with crashes too
you got to film awesome for posterity
fireblade says thank you thanks for your
support of jk rowling mr ellis and your
voice work in dragon age was astounding
i'll always be a colonizer oh you were
did you voice dragon and drag dragon age
inquisition yeah the in all the dragon
age series i'm the voice of commander
well in fact in the first game i think
it was anders but for the preceding
games it was colin commander colin
rutherford and um i was actually you
know they're referencing the color
nights i create for the fan base i
created what i call the color nights and
um jk would would post these pictures
these drawings illustrations by young
kids and i thought that was marvellous
and uh i and her show ali supported jk
so it was a couple of years ago myself
and clancy brown is an actor you
probably saw him in the shawshank
redemption as captain hadley and various
other movies i i just basically said i
see you know support strong women like
jk rowling and and iron her shirley and
then and and clancy retweeted that and
suddenly we were transphobes and racists
and wow a whole bunch of things so
um yeah it was quite odd but uh yeah jk
rowling's quite a
very successful woman and shouldn't we
be cheering successful women or is that
um a bad thing to do
yeah well you know she's a great author
but i don't know about screenplays i
wasn't a fan of the the fantastic beasts
series did she write i didn't know she
was because she did she doesn't write
all the harry potter screenplays does
she i don't think she does no she wrote
the books and then they were yeah i
could be wrong though but uh dragon age
inquisition amazing game yeah one of my
favorites i haven't played it origins
was spectacular too i thought when's the
next one coming out
i would have read about it
i wasn't in it you won't be in it no i'm
not going to be in it is there a reason
why um
well that whole situation no they can't
well they the fan base is pretty you
know uh
well they were very strong in their
opinions and they you know believed that
i was this rabid transphobe and uh
racist and um and i went toe-to-toe with
it it was actually a producer called
mark doubt i think was mark dara and he
would he would find these little uh
twitter threads and post uh bioware's
values uh
uh need to be are reflected in our games
and when we announced the voiceover cam
i'm thinking you
like your values because i've worked
with this company for many and this man
for many years so i called him out and
of course you know that just got me the
eye he didn't hire you again after that
here's the thing it's not where he
didn't hire me i wouldn't have done the
game anyway good for you you know i
don't have a condo i don't have a
franchise contract and i never said i've
never said this till now yeah yeah it's
like i wouldn't want to work with him
yeah calmly it's like you know it's
you don't get to to to go around and
just besmirch people's character and
infer that i am the very thing that a
few people have called me are yeah i
know who i'm not so shut your gob uh if
you want to talk you know he could have
come he could have had a private message
with me could have emailed me he could
have called me he could have said you
know and of course the irony is that you
know there's so many people who are
getting fired
in companies like that because of
inhumane resources because identity
politics devours itself so and people
are afraid in my my industry and
hollywood to speak about it because you
speak about it then suddenly oh you're
one of them well you know what there
isn't a them in us there's there's a
whole populace of people with different
and varying opinions on different
subjects and issues and let's have a
conversation yeah well you made a point
about the fact that he didn't reach out
to you in private and that's that kind
of thing is so scummy to go to the
public with an issue that you have with
a person who you know before speaking
with and it wasn't even in public as
well it was like little
private little twitter threads and this
kind of stock statement from the company
was coming up i'm like don't do that
yeah don't rip yourself apart for
politics
bioware is such a good development
company from for like right 20 i mean
the baldur's gate this is like black
isle entertainment i think they worked
with back in the day
to see it get to lose its best voice
talent because the voice acting video
games are are merging with movies
interactive movies are the future of
entertainment and you need a good voice
actor if you don't have good voice
acting don't do voice acting you need it
it is casting your your stars and man
politics aside get the best actors i
agree it's all it
who is the best person for the job and
with that situation but i love working
with bioware i love i've done over 130
video games and quite a few with them i
love working with them it was this
this loud minority of rabid fans who
just wanted to create this funeral about
me and label me as as someone i wasn't
and then the what dis was disappointed
was the company this huge corporation
who made billions of dollars in this
game
didn't either just stay silent or reach
out to me privately go hey you know what
this is a bit uh
and went after me with like on little
i'm like you just know you know what we
are developing a video game and we will
be kind enough to give you a speaking
role
what character will i play so it's not
gonna tell you it's not that kind of
game i'm half kidding it's a it's it's
like a it's like a platformer rolling i
do like very simple yeah what oh the
library no no it should be the chickens
so
south park is famous for whenever they
get a celebrity guest they make them do
like a dog or a chicken right yeah no
but we are making a video game we'll
we'll show you it's nothing like dragon
age
it's uh it's like a top-down platformer
roguelike game so it's like a gun yeah i
don't want to say too much because it's
not but we got a lot of stuff developed
on it it's pretty fun so far and then
we'll we'll show you there's no real
voice rules or anything in it it's just
like
you know
grunts and jumps do you have any gigs
lined up that you can talk about in the
gaming industry do you know what the
gaming industry has become so nda heavy
um there's one i'm working on right now
given the current conversation i would
love i've been working on it over two
years i would love to talk about it i
can't
um but hopefully at some stage i'll be
able to
say i'd you know i voiced about 30
so far 32 characters it's a a very
successful well-known in one game yeah
um the weirdest thing is when you get
because i do have i've done a lot of
cards like 32 brothers or something no
no all completely different voices yeah
um is is when you have a conversation
with yourself in in in animation in a
scene um so you might be doing two or
three characters yeah so you actually
read through the two or three patterns
very fast and you switch from voice to
voice and inflectively that's something
you do yeah yeah so i have a small
business animation production and we run
a channel called freedom tunes and i i
basically do all the voices
except for tim gust
so freedom tooth is one of the things we
do but we basically have um there's a
couple other clients we serve like
freedom tunes is the it's like sort of
what i put my heart and soul into yeah
do almost all the voices so yeah that is
fun it's tough though
because like sometimes
you almost want to do the voices
separately so you like keep
the exact because when you're switching
from voice to voice sometimes the voice
like loses a little bit of that sound
that's the sign of a great a good
professional voice actor many people can
do it for a few seconds or a sentence or
two as wrote and learning
how can you stay in character yeah you
know
yeah exactly that was the kind of voice
you're doing you know you have to stay
visit for a while you can't just kind of
hello tim how are you actually are you
guys you're doing impersonations that's
very fast now impersonations are not
there are guys in the in the video and
in the video game and voice over world
who are amazing like the uh jeff bennett
and rob paulson and maurice lamarche
robin
robin robin uh maurice of the voice of
pinky in the brain frank welker's
another one uh a living legend the true
living legend a voice over um
impersonations and then there's people
like d bradley baker who's the monster
and creatures sound like everywhere with
d for years he was also a batman wasn't
he
um no no that was diedrick bader i did
this series with uh diedrick the um
batman the brave and the bowl i think
was cool where he played
ghost and uh cavalier and dr fate and dr
fate was kind of like this doctor only
the fan of dr fake can save you yeah so
but many of these voices they just come
in the moment they will just say okay
we've got three more characters uh uh
we're on page 29 uh uh it's uh
what's it mr mind or professor mike i
forget that i'm gonna upset all of the
people um
it's a it's a classic warner brothers
character but
you have to just come up with a voice in
the moment yeah and kind of go to your
rolodex or library of voices and just
kind of see you see sometimes you get an
image of the the character and you'll
have a little character breakdown and
you know what do you see what what's the
what's your interpretation in your in
your mind yeah i'm the voice of doctor
but he's not really prominent in the
media anymore not
now because he's got anymore doesn't he
yeah
well i don't know i don't know if i can
do fauci these it's been a long time
it's been too long
it's funny you mentioned that that's
always been one of the struggles for me
like i have a number of established
characters with unique voices but like
coming up with a new voice for a random
side character stuff and we do like so
for the freedom tunes channel we do a
cartoon every week sometimes too and so
i'm not always able to like throw
everything into a brand new voice and
end up reusing them but one thing i have
found really helps me and this is a tip
i i heard a voice actor saying in an
interview is doing an impression badly
and it ends up sounding like its own new
unique voice
yeah that's really good
there was one show i did transformers
where i came onto the show it had
already been recorded and the great tim
curry was the voice of dr morocco in
transformers the animated rescue bots it
was called and he got sick and he
couldn't carry on the voice director
kind of knew that i might be able to
match him and his
kind of doctor morocco yeah very chewy
kind of voice and it was almost like
three voices in one where he got an
easily there and then you knew the hand
of dr morocco
that was kamala harris's doctor
so so like how can you like almost like
a bad impersonation or somewhat good
impersonation of someone famous
yeah pulling pulling from that yeah all
right let's read some more we got um
evangelize of uh evangelize to the world
says hey it's commander giles price red
alert three is a fantastic game love the
cheesy scenes
wow red alert i remember that that was
uh we filmed that i filmed that in cost
it was rare for a video game getting in
costume with camera and and actually
filming like a like a i guess like a
movie and doing scenes and that's rare
for any video yeah it was like one of
the first games i remember having oh did
you play you played it commander conquer
red alert see i haven't played hardly
any of the games that i've i've i
remember going to a dragon age
convention and playing with myself
the character i mean not playing yeah
and with the fans
i was like wow this game is because i
you grew up on asteroids and stand-up
video arcade games with like defender
track and field and all you know pac-man
and uh so to see that how it becomes
like the games are phenomenal i think to
a degree that that that kind of bridge
between the virtual uh reality of being
in a video game with its own set of
belief systems and values
how and particularly with uh the younger
generation disappearing into those games
and device dependency how do you get
your value system back in the real world
it must be challenging at times because
you can get lost in that video game it's
so believable oh yeah dragon age was
amazing let's just read as many as we
can we'll get some more super chats in
korean jinx says did you see dankilla's
troll tweet earlier today justice
dankula was comedy gold
so count dankula that was very funny
photoshopped an image for his twitter
profile of him
wearing a judge's robe with like nice
hair
changed his name to justice dankula
and started tweeting things like uh he
said i hereby declare the itty bitty
titty committee to be a terrorist
organization and people thought he was
actually a supreme court justice and
they're tweeting at them like you'll
regret what you did overturning roe v
wade or stuff like that and it's just
remarkable exposing these people
having no idea what they're protesting
it was like a it's dankula there's no
supreme court justice named dankula
but they thought it was true
that's the whole joke
dankula it was amazing i i thought it
was fantastic
all right let's grab some more
pursuit of happiness says tim according
to the fraser institute west virginia
ranks 47th in economic freedom in the
u.s beating only new york california and
vermont help us change this i will
i've actually um
i found some things in west virginia to
be restricted which is surprising but
it's yeah better than maryland that is
surprising i had no idea they ranked
that low
yeah i mean
i don't know if that makes sense
like what is their criteria for economic
freedom because we've been setting up
like the headquarters like it's so easy
relative to other places i've been well
that's because you're breaking the law
though oh yeah
yeah no you can't do that like we waited
six months for an internet permit oh my
goodness yeah an internet permit and
they were supposed to wait well to build
an internet line oh it's been six months
and then they're finally like it's been
approved and now it's like but we have
no materials
it's like wow so we could have the new
hq built within the next two months and
have no internet not be able to to move
until we get it set up
hear that e-line so that's nice oh we
have something oh really yeah it's just
not good enough yeah here's that elon we
we do have we do have two
starlink we have two sonic and we can
bond them together for a whopping eight
megabits up
huh starlink bondage is not enough
not enough
not enough and i i i would be surprised
if we actually got eight because we're
gonna have two relatively two satellites
relatively close together or two dishes
and you're probably gonna get a marginal
return by bonding the two of them when
you talk about more than one star link
do you say stars link or star links
what attorneys general yeah
all right let's grab some more
calvin rams says tim you claim that
biden is a puppet and reads note cards
which is true but then hoist the idea
that he's mumbled in order out of a rat
confused
uh i i didn't say he was a puppet
we talked about him reading the cards
but having people give you cards to
explain what you're supposed to do
doesn't mean that you're working for
someone
i think it's likely that joe biden like
people are watching him being like i
don't care what he says or does it's not
it's i'm not him he's responsible for it
he's taking the fall for everybody are
these the cards we're talking about with
like you sit in the chat yeah no yeah
that's not working for someone that's
like having an aide if you're working
for someone who's telling you to do that
that is horrific micromanagement like
you sit in that chair and say that it's
just
as president you you do need a little
direction you do need to know at certain
points okay this is the moment you do
this
because you have to get through the
criteria of the day and and yeah i just
i think he needs a lot of direction
which is the difference i agree like a
president does need a little direction
this guy i don't even know where to
begin
all right let's see jake turbin says
send out a super chat earlier just want
my name read on here for my wife haha
congratulations there you go
i don't know you guys says dude ian you
need to chill on your adderall hate some
of us legitimately have a very hard time
with executive executive function
without it do you think it's ethical to
give 14 year olds amphetamines
i don't i want to hear from the guy that
just made that tweet what was it all
right uh um i don't know you guys was a
new i don't know you guys says bioware
is a zombie wearing the skin of its
founders the doctors it's a bloody
horrible video game company now that
couldn't write a meaningful sentence let
alone a paragraph how do you really feel
yeah yeah that's pretty brutal
wow that's sad
did they do that what was that one game
that flopped really bad uh what was it i
can't think it was a space game you know
what i'm talking about
which one oh no man's sky is that no no
that was bad though but they recovered
no man's sky it's way better now no
there was some video game about like
people in outer space and there were
aliens or something and like everyone
was making math blasters that was
awesome for that one
when the aliens are trying to take your
castle over and you have to solve the
math equations oh that doesn't that
doesn't sound exciting math blah blah
blah you know what well
when you went to the computer lab
crack the teeth on the wrong on the
wrong answer
dude
um bioware did shadows baldur's gate and
balder's gate two did you guys play
those the most one of the greatest video
games ever made at that point in history
if you like role-playing games yeah
baldur's gate changed the world it was
like the introduction of dungeons and
dragons into like a top-down isometric
video game all right we're gonna go to
the members only show so head over to
timcast.com and become a member to help
support our work and you will get access
to the exclusive members only show which
will be up about 11 p.m don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you like it
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
you can follow me personally on tim cast
follow us follow both follow both
accounts on instagram greg do you want
to shout anything out uh yeah the
respondent.com um that was
that's really the place for everything
to do with the respondent my book the
respondent exposing the cartel family
law um that has information about my
charity cpu children parents united uh
we're helping find relief for people
stuck in the family law court system and
uh calling out those who make false
allegations of dv as recently happened
with uh
johnny depp and number heard um
and my twitter alice greg
i'm seamus coughlin of freedom tunes we
have a new website it's called
freedomtunes.com if you go over there
for five bucks a month you will get an
extra cartoon each week you'll also be
supporting independent content you also
get behind the scenes stuff as well i
want to mention we did a video on friday
which the audience has really seemed to
enjoy it's five minutes long uh it's
it's me reviewing pro-choicers and
pro-abortion people freaking out over
the supreme court decision there is a
12-minute long version of that behind
our paywall far extended so go over to
freedomtunes.com if you want to see that
i love you all i'm really glad you're go
looking so deep into family law i've
been really harping on no fault divorce
these days and recently found out that
the it was basically the russian
revolutionaries the communist lenin and
his friends that established no fault
divorce you know what easy way to break
up the family really it's new yeah it's
it's a good point and it's just been
introduced in the uk um and many people
think it's a good thing and it's not a
good thing and you know what
i was saying before the show there's a
reason that you know america is the
world leader in children growing up in
single parent households we have 4 000
children a day losing a parent in family
law courts the states are reimbursed six
thousand dollars for every child their
place that they place into foster care
um law enforcement is incentivized by
stop grants to keep the children in
foster care and then bonuses to move
them into adoption
and all of this started or much of it
started in 1974 by the um twistedly
named uh violence against women act
which was joe biden some legislation and
they've just renewed that and yeah it's
it's a horrific situation for so many
families across america and it's only
going to get worse in the uk just to
point out your uh your book again where
can people get it um they can find it at
the respondent.com they can also find it
at any good bookseller online or
otherwise and we also have i should
mention the community the respondent
community which i've started which is a
safe space for people who are who are
stuck in the divorce trap or um have
been alienated from their children or
children alienated from their parents
um and really just giving some hope i
think is that's why i wrote the book i
didn't want to write the book i had to
write the book um and to let you know a
lot of a lot of people who were stuck in
the system know that they're not alone
um you know the the you know the other
day i had a phone call from well i got
an email i get emails every day was an
email from a vet uh
he he was he lost his arms and his legs
in an ied he's laying in hospital and he
gets served a false allegation of
domestic violence that i call it the
silver bullet of domestic violence he
comes back to america in a wheelchair no
arms no legs and for the last eight
years he's been fighting himself
representing himself in family court and
he's homeless
these stories are not you know random
stories there are tens if not hundreds
of thousands of of people parents mostly
forsaken fathers and dads or spouses
that are going through this and a lot of
women and mothers too and
for some reason it's the national health
emergency that nobody seems to be
talking about because if we can bring
jurors prudence and the presumption of
innocence into family law
we can provide parents and families the
same rights that criminals terrorists
pedophiles murderers get and you would
think that families should have that in
america of all places
this isn't a left versus right issue
this is a fundamental human rights issue
and this is what i talk about a lot of
the time and hopefully we can bring
about change we are bringing about
change we've got some i've been working
with the legislature in ohio we're
bringing in 50 50 share parenting there
it's the third state to do that we're
going to move to missouri next and then
oklahoma and and keep going but there's
so much work to be done so the
respondent and the respondent community
is is the place for people anyone
interested in that to help out thanks
man wow
that i just want to say that's like the
most important thing anyone has said all
shown it came at the very end which is
why you want to watch to the end folks
that's right got to watch all the way
through to the end yeah his book looked
really amazing he also got johnny depp
and alec baldwin to endorse it which is
really interesting combination of people
um so yeah go ahead and go over and
check that out for sure that sounds
really important you guys can follow me
on twitter and mines.com at
sarahpatchlist on uh
sourpatchlids.me
all right everybody we will see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out bye guys
you